Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und das hier ist die 30. Ausgabe und vermutlich auch die letzte im Jahr 2011. Das Thema soll heute sein, eine Mission, die ja schon eine Weile unterwegs ist, aber noch lange nicht abgeschlossen ist, die auch eine besondere Mission ist in vielerlei Hinsicht. Und zwar handelt es hier um Cassini-Huygens. Und als Gesprächspartner für diese Ausgabe begrüße ich Michael, Michael Khan. Hallo.
Hallo.
Ja, du bist hier, wir befinden uns in Darmstadt am ESOC, der ESA. Und du bist hier als Luft- und Raumfahrtingenieur tätig im Bereich der Missionsplanung.
Missionsanalyse.
Richtig. Und hast du das auch schon seit einiger Zeit, richtig? Seit wann so?
Also seit jetzt im zwölften Jahr bin ich jetzt in der Missionsanalyse und vorher war ich auch schon mal da.
Und wie war so dein Weg hier zur ESA? Womit hat das alles angefangen?
Die ESA hat ein Trainee-Programm für Graduierte, also für Leute, die gerade ihr Studium abgeschlossen haben. Und darüber bin ich in die ESA gekommen. Das war 1988, nach meinem Zivildienst. Und dann war ich über zehn Jahre noch in der Industrie, hier und dort, in Amerika, in Deutschland, in verschiedenen Orten. Und dann hat sich hier eine Möglichkeit ergeben. Und dann bin ich permanent hier wieder.
In der Raumfahrtindustrie oder in irgendeiner Industrie?
Ich war zeitweise in der Raumfahrtindustrie. Und dann gab es ein großes Loch in der Raumfahrtbranche, also insbesondere in der Forschung in den 90er-Jahren. Da habe ich ganz andere Sachen gemacht. Das hat gar nichts mit Raumfahrt zu tun.
Aber dann hat sich doch wieder hierher gezogen.
Ja, das war vielleicht meine letzte Chance, wieder in das, was ich eigentlich mein Leben lang machen wollte, zurückzukommen.
Also es war eigentlich von Anfang an das Ziel?
Das ist schon seit meinem siebten Lebensjahr das Ziel.
Aha, warum genau das siebte?
Da war die Apollo-Landung, die Apollo 11-Mondlandung.
Die scheint damals wirklich allen in den Kopf verdreht zu haben.
Also ich denke, wenn man das so mitgemacht hat und das Gefühl mitgenommen hat, vor allen Dingen, als kleiner Junge versteht man die technischen Daten nicht und man versteht sehr wohl, wie wichtig das für alle ist und wie das alle mitnimmt und die Begeisterung. Das will man halt mitmachen, das will man auch mal machen.
Das scheint auch wirklich ein einmaliger Event gewesen zu sein. Hat sich das eigentlich seitdem noch mal bei irgendeiner Mission wiederholt oder ist das eigentlich gar nicht mehr zu toppen mit der Mondlandung?
Ja, also eine bemannte Mondlandung, das erste Mal, wo Menschen wirklich den Fuß auf einen fremden Himmelskörper setzen, das ist natürlich nicht wiederholbar und ich bin wirklich froh, dass ich finde, das ist der definierende Moment der Menschheitsgeschichte, also wirklich der Moment, wo man sagen kann, die Menschheit ist jetzt erwachsen geworden. Aber jetzt vielleicht mit nur ganz geringer Übertreibung, würde ich sagen, dass Huygens ein bisschen was davon hatte, weil da auch wirklich eine ganz neue Welt in Beschlag genommen wurde und das Feeling war nicht nur bei mir, sondern auch weltweit doch ähnlich.
Auch wenn hier keine Menschen auf den anderen Himmelskörper aufgetreten sind, ist zumindest Menschengemachtes auf den anderen Himmelskörper aufgetreten.
Ja, dass man also einen weiten Weg zurückgelegt hat, dass man viele Gefahren gemeistert hat und dass man etwas gesehen hat, was so eines Menschenaugen noch nie gesehen hatte. Das war wirklich, also mit großer Spannung haben wir auf die ersten Bilder gewartet und als die dann kamen, da waren wir alle hin und weg.
Wahrscheinlich könnte nur eine bemannte Mission zum Mars dann nochmal ein ähnliches Feuer wecken, oder?
Also ich denke, das muss nicht am Mars sein, auf Asteroiden oder auch selbst zurück zum Mond, das würde doch eine ähnliche Begeisterung hervorrufen. Auch wenn viele Leute sagen, ja, das haben wir alle schon mal gemacht, das stimmt so nicht. Also wenn die auf dem Südpol des Mondes landen würden, das wäre eine Landschaft, also da sag ich ihnen, das Bild würde jeder in seinem Zimmer hängen haben wollen.
Ja, also, du bist schon eine Weile dabei, so viel ist klar geworden. Da waren auch einige Missionen von Tangiert. Weiß nicht, mit was bist du in Berührung gekommen in der Zeit?
Also ich hab eigentlich fast nur mit planetaren Missionen zu tun. Und da ist es eigentlich alles. Ich hab an Studien gearbeitet für Merkow-Missionen, Merkow-Lander, Mond, eine ganze Menge, Asteroiden, jede Menge, Mars, jede Menge. Also auch Missionen, die jetzt wirklich in der konkreten Planung sind. Exo-Mars. Bis hin zu bemannten Missionen. Ich hab also wirklich an der Planung von bemannten Missionen mitgearbeitet.
Du bist ja auch selber am Bloggen, auf den Cylogs, Cosmologs, auf der Plattform. Go for Launch heißt es. Worum geht es dabei?
Der Untertitel dieses Blogs ist Raumfahrt aus der Froschperspektive. Und ich möchte wirklich mal so zeigen, wie einer, der drin ist, aber nicht besonders hoch oben sitzt, sondern sich mit den technischen Details auskennt, das alles wahrnimmt.
Darum geht es ja auch hier bei Raumzeit. Cassini-Huygens, jetzt haben wir es schon ein paar mal angedeutet, eine spezielle Mission, eine Mission zum Saturn, beziehungsweise um es genau zu nehmen, eine Mission zum Saturn und auch zum Mond des Saturns, Titan. Also Monde hat ja der Saturn so einige, aber Titan ist in vielerlei Hinsicht auch ein besonderes Objekt. Hier können wir sicherlich auch gleich noch mal drüber sprechen oder fangen wir doch damit eigentlich mal an. Warum Saturn?
Also genau gesagt ist es eine Mission zum Saturnsystem und so wurde es auch immer dargestellt. Also das ist alles. Der Saturn ist nur als System zu verstehen, mit seinem Mond, mit seinem Ring, mit seinem Magnetfeld, mit dem Staub, mit dem Wasser, mit allem, was es da gibt. Und der Saturn ist der nächste logische Schritt. Die Amerikaner hatten ja Galileo am Jupiter und dann Ende der 80er Jahre war der Vorschlag, dass man jetzt Saturn in Angriff nimmt. Und 1989 wurde das sogenannte Kick-Off gegeben, wurde das angestoßen, die Entwicklung. Und davor war eigentlich immer geplant, also anfangs war geplant, dass die Europäer den Orbiter machen und die Amerikaner den Lander auf den Titan. Denn man wusste schon immer, dass der Titan ein ganz besonders interessanter Körper ist, ein Mond, der eine dichte Atmosphäre hat. Der einzige Mond im Sonnensystem, der eine dichte Atmosphäre hat. Das ist also wirklich ein ganz außergewöhnliches Objekt. Und dann hat sich das im Laufe der Entwicklung aber umgedreht und die Amerikaner haben jetzt den Cassini-Orbiter gebaut, also das große Mutterschiff, das den Saturn umkreist und an seinen Monden vorbeifliegt und die Ringe untersucht und das Magnetwinter untersucht. Und die Europäer haben sich darauf gestürzt, diesen Huygens-Lander für den titan-atmosphärischen Flug zu bauen.
Also eine Kombimission in technischer und organisationstechnischer Hinsicht auch. NASA-ESA-Mission war eigentlich so die erste Kooperation dieser Art zwischen NASA und ESA, oder?
Ja, ich überlege gerade. Es war die erste große Mission zwischen NASA und ESA von dieser Größe, ja sicher. Galileo zum Jupiter war eine deutsch-amerikanische Mission. Da haben die Deutschen sehr viel beigetragen. Und vor allen Dingen eine Mission, die mir völlig unverdient in Vergessenheit geraten ist, das ist Helios. Das war die erste interplanetare Mission der Deutschen. Und da haben die Deutschen 70 Prozent geleistet, die Amerikaner 30 Prozent. Und das war wirklich eine Mission, die auf die Dichter an die Sonne angekommen ist als der Merkur. Kennt heute keiner mehr. Und das war eine unglaublich kühne Mission. Vor allen Dingen vor dem Hintergrund, dass man zu der Zeit, als die gestartet wurde, also es war Anfang der 70er, da hatten die Deutschen noch nicht mal, die deutsche Industrie hat nicht mal einen Satelliten gebaut. Und da machen die gleich sowas. Das finde ich wirklich toll.
Das war auch erfolgreich.
Das war erfolgreich, ja.
Das heißt, bei dem Galileo-Projekt war die ESA noch nicht beteiligt?
Die ESA war nicht in der Rolle beteiligt, also so wie jetzt hier bei Cassini-Huygens. Das ist ein richtiger Partner.
Wie kommt es dann dazu? Warum sagt die NASA nicht einfach, jetzt haben wir den Jupiter genommen, jetzt nehmen wir den Saturn? Warum wird das dann aufgeteilt? Ist das eine Frage von Kompetenzen, Geldsparen?
Ja, Geld, das ist wahrscheinlich eine finanzielle Frage. Aber es gibt immer Kooperationen mit wissenschaftlichen Instituten. Da ist es zum Beispiel bekannt, dass die Deutschen besonders gut darin sind, Kameras zu bauen für interplanetare Missionen. Also überall, wenn sie schauen, überall bei den Missionen, die zu Asteroiden fliegen oder irgendwo hin, da ist immer zumindest ein großer Anteil an der Kameratechnik in Deutsch. Und offensichtlich ist da eben eine große Erfahrung da. Viele deutsche Instrumente, zum Beispiel der Fobos-Grund, der leider jetzt nicht erfolgreichen Fobos-Missionen, da ist auch ein deutsches Instrument dabei. Also es gibt Kompetenz und die Amerikaner sind erfolgsorientiert und die nehmen halt den Partner, bei dem es davon ausgeht, dass die Chancen des Erfolgs der Missionen vergrößert sind pragmatisch.
Was wusste man denn zu dem Zeitpunkt überhaupt schon über den Saturn? Also der Start von Cassini-Huygens war 1997. Das war jetzt die erste wirklich nennenswert größere Mission, die sich ausschließlich dem Saturn-System gewidmet hat. Was hatte man denn bislang in der Raumfahrt schon vom Saturn einfangen können?
Also man hatte von Pioneer und Voyager schon zumindest Nahaufnahmen, anders als nur teleskopische Aufnahmen von der Erde. Man hatte auch Durchflüge des Ringsystems in größerer Entfernung. Man wusste, dass es zumindest theoretisch geht. Wenn man jetzt aufpasst, dass man nicht in die Zonen ganz starker Flussdichte von Staub- und Trümmerteilchen kommt, Regenteilchen, und man wusste, dass der Titan, dieser Mond, Titan, der größte Mond des Saturn, der zweitgrößte Mond im Sonnensystem, dass der eben eine dichte Atmosphäre hat und man wusste, dass die in hohen, also dass die aus Stickstoff ist und doch einiges Methan enthält.
Wusste man das jetzt von den Pioneer- und Voyager-Missionen oder durch Erdbeobachtung von der Erde aus?
Die Zusammensetzung der Atmosphäre wusste man, man hatte ungefähre Daten und die wusste man durch Beobachtung von der Erde aus, durch spektroskopische Untersuchungen und durch Sternenokultationen. Also wenn ein Stern scheinbar hinter dem Titan vorbeizieht, der umgekehrte Titan zieht vorher im Stern vorbei, dann kann man an der Verdunkelung des Sterns sehen, wie dicht, wie stark die hohe Atmosphäre ist und was da drin ist.
Das heißt, dem Ganzen ist einfach eine jahrelange Beobachtung dieser Objekte vorausgegangen. Saturn sowieso, aber eben auch Titan, sodass man sich sicher war, dass der Titan jetzt ein lohnenswertes Ziel war.
Ja, also bei Titan waren die Erwartungen sehr hoch gesteckt. Es gab Theorien darüber, dass es vielleicht einen Ozean gibt. Auf der Oberfläche, also der Methan-Ozean, dass die Oberfläche komplett von dem Ozean bedeckt ist. Deswegen war Huygens auch so gebaut, dass sie zumindest für eine Zeit schwimmfähig ist, wenn sie in Methan aufgesetzt wäre. Gerade das Methan als Kohlenwasserstoffverbindung, also das organische Verbindung ist für die Exobiologen von besonderem Interesse, weil man eben weiß, dass wenn man Kohlenwasserstoffe nimmt, dann hat man auch noch Stickstoff in der Atmosphäre und dann hat man Energie durch die ultraviolette Strahlung der Sonne und durch die kosmische Strahlung. Wenn man alles zusammenrührt, dann kann man eben durchaus komplexe organische Chemie kommen und dann ist man gar nicht mehr so sehr weit von Vorstufen des Lebens. Also wirklich komplexe organische Chemie ist ein Schritt auf dem Weg hin zu Kohlenstoff-basiertem Leben, wie wir es kennen.
Aber durch diese Beobachtung und Spektroskopie kann man zwar in etwa sagen, was dort ist, aber man muss schon wirklich näher ran, um wirklich eine finale Aussage machen zu können, in welcher Form und in welchen Mengen etwas vorhanden ist.
Ja, man kann eben aus so großer Entfernung, spektroskopisch, kann man nicht wirklich Spurngase genau bestimmen. Man kann zwar sagen, da ist Methan, das ungefähr so und so viel, aber es gibt natürlich auch andere Kohlenstoffverbindungen, die dadurch entstehen, dass Methan zerfällt und sich anders wieder zusammensetzt. Das kann man, wenn es geringe Konzentrationen sind, so nicht feststellen und was man auch wissen will, was sehr wichtig ist für die Frage nach der, wo diese Kohlenwasserstoffverbindungen herkommen, dann will man wissen, die Isotopenzusammensetzung. Ob das jetzt Kohlenstoff 12 ist mit insgesamt sechs Protonen und Neutronen oder vielleicht Kohlenstoff 13. Das klingt jetzt ein bisschen technisch, aber das ist wichtig, wenn man wissen will, ob das auf biologischen oder nicht biologischen Wegen entstanden ist. Dazu muss man die Frage kennen und dazu muss man wirklich hinfliegen und vor Ort nachmessen.
Wäre man denn auch hingeflogen, wenn es den Titanen nicht gegeben hätte in der Form? Ist der Saturn an sich schon interessant genug? Oder war es eigentlich der Titan, der erst richtig das Interesse geweckt hat?
Ich vermute, dass der Titan wirklich einen Ausschlag gegeben hat. Es ist ja erstaunlich, dass man für den Galileo, der zum Jupiter geflogen ist, eine Eintrittssonde für den Jupiter mitgenommen hat. Das hat man mit dem Saturn nicht mal gemacht. Es wäre ja eigentlich naheliegend gewesen, dass man auch versucht, eine Eintrittssonde mitzunehmen, die in die Atmosphäre vom Saturn eintritt. Hat man nicht gemacht. Man hat also den Titan vorgezogen.
Weil man schon meinte, man weiß schon, genug oder Titan ist einfach viel interessanter.
Ja, also weil man wahrscheinlich, gut, ich meine, wenn man jetzt unbegrenzt Mittel zur Verfügung gehabt hätte, hätte man beides gemacht, aber wenn man Prioritäten setzen müssen, hat man dem Titan Vorrang gegeben.
Reise zum Saturn ist ja ganz schön eine Strecke, die da zurückgelegt werden muss. Was für ein Objekt ist erforderlich? Was für Anforderungen muss man denn einplanen, um so eine Reise überhaupt erst mal unternehmen zu können?
Also, ob man jetzt zum Saturn filtert, zum Jupiter, das macht dann den Kohle auch nicht mehr fett. Was auf jeden Fall gemacht werden muss, ist Vorbeiflüge an den inneren Planeten. Im Fall von Cassini waren es halt zwei Venus-Vorbeiflüge, einen Erdtorbeiflug und dann noch mal am Jupiter Schwung geholt. Das Problem dabei war, dass die Cassini-Raumsonde drei radioisotopen Generatoren an Bord hatte und diesen mit Plutonium bestückt. Da wollte man auf jeden Fall verhindern, dass selbst im Falle eines Problems, dass die Kontrolle der Sonde jetzt ausschließt, also wenn die Sonde unterwegs verreckt und man kann sie nicht mehr kontrollieren, dass er dann trotzdem noch beim Vorbeiflug an der Erde aufgrund eines Navigationsfehles auf die Erde stürzt. Das war praktisch das dominierende Problem bei dem ganzen Entwurf des Hinflugs. Das war immer das Problem, das man da zu beachten hätte und das Problem auch gelöst.
Wozu war dieses Instrument an Bord?
Die Plutoniumbatterien sind dazu da, um Strom zu erzeugen. Das Zerf zerstört Plutonium, erzeugt Wärme und die Wärme erzeugt Strom.
Das ist atomgetrieben war.
Atomgetrieben ist kein besonderes klarer Begriff. Das sagt jetzt nicht so viel aus. Das ist halt eine Art der Stromversorgung, die ohne Sonnenenergie auskommt. Denn davon hat man da draußen nicht mehr genug. Der Saturn ist ungefähr zehnmal so weit weg von der Sonne wie wir. Das heißt, das Sonnendicht ist ungefähr ein Prozent von dem, was wir hier haben. Und die Solargeneratoren vor allen Dingen in so einer staubreichen Umgebung ist nicht unbedingt, da kann man nicht einen Fußballfeldgroßen Solargenerator mitnehmen. Der wird da nicht lange aushalten.
Aber den bräuchte man eigentlich.
Den bräuchte man, ja.
Okay, also das heißt, Cassini-Huygens ist gestartet und musste erstmal zur Venus?
Musste zweimal zur Venus und dann einmal eine Erdeschwung holen, jedes Mal wurde Schwung geholt.
Also erst zu Venus, dann zu Erde, dann nochmal zu Venus.
Venus, Venus, Erde. Ja, Venus, ein Manöver, ein Triebwerksmanöver, dann nochmal Venus und dann Erde und dann ging es raus zum Jupiter. Dann einmal am Jupiter und dann raus zum Saturn und am Jupiter wurden, also ich weiß nicht wieviel, aber enorm viele Bilder noch gemacht. Die ganze Kamera wurde schon kalibriert und selbst Bilder großer wissenschaftlicher Bedeutung wurden beim Vorbeiflug am Jupiter gemacht.
Bei der Venus nicht?
Bei der Venus weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob da die Kamera schon verwendet wurde, ist mir jetzt nicht bekannt. Beim Mond ja, bei Mond wurden tatsächlich auch einige Instrumente kalibriert.
Würde man jetzt eigentlich vermuten, dass man schon auch so eine Gelegenheit, wenn man eh schon bei der Venus vorbeikommt, dass man dann auch noch irgendwie was mitnimmt? Oder war der Abstand da zu groß, um sinnvoll zu sein?
Ich müsste jetzt spekulieren, ich müsste mal nachschauen, aber mir ist jetzt nicht bekannt, dass da eine Venus viel gemacht wurde. Vielleicht ist es mir auch nur entfallen, aber vielleicht ist es auch nur so, weil mir die Jupiter-Wilder mehr in Erinnerung geblieben sind, weil der Jupiter ist halt interessanter zu sehen aufgrund seiner Wolkenstruktur.
Ist das jetzt so zu dem Zeitpunkt, also wann fing das an mit der Planung? Die konkrete Planung, 89, also acht Jahre bis zum Start.
Was übrigens jetzt ja kurze Zeit ist.
Ja, finde ich auch, weil das ja dann auch durch quasi so eine Doppelmission ist, durchaus komplex ist, gut zwar jetzt auch auf zwei Raumfahrtagenturen verteilt, aber war denn so das Wissen schon so weit, dass man jetzt so problemlos diese Flugbahnen hat berechnen können oder mussten da irgendwelche neuen Kniffe erfunden werden?
Die Berechnung der Flugbahn ist jetzt nicht das Problem. Das Problem ist, dass man, also bei Raumsonden ist es generell so, man hat ein gewisses Wissen über die Umgebung, wo man hinfliegt und dafür legt man die Sonde aus. Und dann gibt es eine gewisse Unsicherheit in dieser Umgebung und dafür hat man sogenannte, wir reden ja hier Englisch oder zumindest oder richtiges Englisch oder Euroenglisch.
Jaja, wir können ja auf jeden Fall Raumfahrtspeak sprechen.
Ja, also Raumfahrtsprech heißt das Margins. Also, wie heißt das denn noch?
Ränder, Schutzräumer.
Ne, ne, ne, Margins sind einfach Sicherheitsmargen. Ja, Sicherheitsmargen, genau. Also man berechnet, wie viel Belastung die Raumsonde nach bestem Wissen und Gewissen ausgesetzt sein wird und dann schlägt man noch ein bisschen was drauf und dann noch ein bisschen zur Sicherheit. Und im Ende ist das alles eine Frage von Geld, weil Sicherheitsmargen sind im Ende Masse, irgendwie immer Masse. Also wenn ich ein Hitzeschild für den Eintritt in die Atmosphäre mache und ich denke mir, hm, die Geschwindigkeit, ja, die kann ich einigermaßen genau berechnen, aber die Zusammensetzung in die Atmosphäre weiß ich jetzt nicht so genau und deswegen auch nicht die Abrämsung, also schlage ich da die über 20 Prozent drauf, dann ist der Hitzeschild eben noch schwerer. Und diese Masse muss ich irgendwie hinbringen und dazu brauche ich eben mehr Masse für die Raumsonde und dazu brauche ich mehr Masse für die Rakete, mehr Kraft für die Rakete und dadurch wird die Rakete teurer. Und am Ende landet immer alles beim Geld. Und wenn man gleich von vornherein sagt, ok, diese Mission ist kühn, diese Mission ist mit Unsicherheiten behaftet und die Unsicherheiten muss ich dadurch minimieren, dass ich eben ordentliche Margen vorsehe und deswegen stelle ich auch ordentlich Kohle zur Verfügung, dann schafft man das in acht Jahren. Teurer am Ende oder schwieriger und zeitaufwendiger und mit vielen unnötigen Hin- und Herschleifen wird es in dem Moment, wo man sagt, das Geld gibt es nicht, Leute, dann müsst ihr schon zusehen, wie ihr mit weniger Geld klarkommt, als ihr eigentlich braucht. Und dann stellt man fest, dass man da unheimlich viele Schleifen dreht, wenn man versucht, diese Probleme zu lösen und es einfach nicht schafft. Und das war in diesem Fall eben nicht so. Und ich denke, das ist die Erklärung, warum Cassini eben lief. Weil die Leute gesagt haben, von vornherein, die Ingenieure haben gesagt, das ist nur mit 3 Milliarden zu machen. Und dann sagte man von oben, okay, 3 Milliarden gibt es.
Und es gab vor allem auch nur dieses eine Zeitfenster, was sich anbote, vermutlich, weil die Konstellation, um jetzt wirklich effektiv so weit hinzukommen, ergibt sich ja auch nicht am laufenden Meter, oder?
Ja, ich denke, zu unseren Toren geht es noch. Also wenn man da noch weiter raus wollte, dann hat man Schwierigkeiten, Fenster zu finden. Hat man dieses kleine Torproblem, das damals die Voyager Leute hatten. Ich glaube, zu unseren Toren wird es noch gehen.
Das heißt, man kann da auch 2 Jahre später starten können?
Ja, obwohl das dann auch immer eine Frage ist. Da muss man halt mehr Treibstoff mitnehmen, das sind auch wieder Masse.
Also man hat schon versucht, den optimalen Zeitpunkt zu erwischen?
Das auf jeden Fall, ja.
Und hat man ihn auch erwischt?
Also es war schon ein ziemlich guter Zeitpunkt, muss ich sagen. Selbst wenn es nicht der optimale war, war der schon ziemlich gut gewählt.
Ok, der Start war dann 1997. Wie groß war dann das gesamte Cassini-Huygens-Gebilde? War das jetzt auch so fett, wie man sich das nur vorstellen kann?
Ja, sogar noch ein Stück fetter. Also das war wirklich ein Riesentrum. Ich habe da Bilder gesehen, wo Techniker daneben stehen und da türmt sich das Ding fast 6 Meter groß auf. Das ist beeindruckend. Man kennt ja die Mars-Sonde, die wir hatten, oder Smart 1, das war so ein Kühlschrank. Mars-Express war eine Telefonzelle mal eine zweite Telefonzelle nebeneinander. Und das Ding hier, das ist eine Litfast-Säule und dann noch eine drauf, das ist dann schon ordentlich. Und ja, auch 3 Tonnen Gewicht beim Start, Masse beim Start, das ist schon etwas, was man normalerweise eigentlich nur vorher, zu der Zeit zumindest, schickte man sowas, gerade als Fernsehsatelliten, in 36.000 Kilometer Höhe. Und dass man so ein Riesen-Monstrum da jetzt rausschickt zum sechsten Planeten, das ist schon bemerkenswert. Ja, das ergibt sich wieder aus der Robustheit. Also, wenn man alles redundant machen muss, vor allen Dingen auch, wenn man dann zum Beispiel, man muss relativ dicht ran an den Saturn, denn nur in relativer Dichte zum Zentralkörper ist das Bremsmanöver einigermaßen effizient. Da hat man immer die Ringe, da musste man also durch eine Lücke in den Ringen rein, Bremsziebwerke zünden, dann das Ding wieder drehen, sodass die Antenne, die auch als Meteoritenschild ausgelegt war, richtig dicke Antenne, richtig massiv, dass die dann wieder in Flugrichtung zeigte und dann durch eine enge Lücke in den Ringen wieder raus.
Warum musste man denn überhaupt durch die Ringe?
Man musste dicht ran, weil nur in dichter Nähe zum Saturn und das Bremsmanöver effizient war. Sonst wäre es einfach nicht machbar gewesen.
Aber die Ringe, die bewegen sich doch im Wesentlichen alle so auf einer Ebene. Die hätte man doch auch komplett ignorieren können.
Das ist bahnmechanisch leider nicht möglich. Man muss schon eine Bahn fliegen, in deren Zentrum, in deren Bremspunkt, der Mittelpunkt des Saturn liegt. Da muss man zwangsläufig...
Irgendwie muss man auf jeden Fall durch die Ringe durch.
Man muss durch die Ringe durch und sogar zweimal. Das war das Problem. Mit dem Triebwerk, das ja auch nicht ganz einwandfrei, nie ganz voraussehbar funktioniert, sondern vielleicht ein bisschen stärker oder weniger stark als man es erwartet hat, das ist immer so bei Raketentriebwerken, dass man dann am Ende, wenn das Triebwerk ausgebrannt ist, immer noch so gezielt ist, dass man durch die zweite Lücke in den Ring wieder rausfliegt und nicht dann mitten da durch die Zone fliegt, wo es ganz dick kommt mit den Teilchen. Und all diese Anforderungen, also diese dicke Antenne, der Menge Treibstoff, der solide Bau, das führt natürlich zu einer gewissen Masse. Das ist einfach unvermeidbar.
Also das Ding musste vor allem einfach stabil sein.
Ja, das ist ein Panzer.
Das ist jetzt gar nicht so sehr, dass da jetzt so viele Instrumente untergebracht wurden, die alle so viel Platz einnehmen, sondern es ist einfach die pure Robustheit, um der Mission überhaupt widerstehen zu können.
Richtig, ja. Die Robustheit und aufgrund der Entfernung muss die natürlich auch eine gewisse Schlauheit haben. Die muss natürlich schon eine gewisse Autonomie haben. Und die muss sich um sich selbst kümmern können. Man hat da schon einen großen sogenannten Kommandostapel, wo man eben schon weit im Voraus ablegen kann. Jetzt mach dies, jetzt drehst du dich 30 Grad nach rechts und dann guckst du da hin, dann drehst du dich wieder nach links und schaltest die Kamera ein und dann machst du das. Und das muss die alles alleine können. Und wenn der Hauptcomputer ausfällt, muss der Nebencomputer übernehmen. Und alles Memory, das muss auch mehrfach redundant vorliegen. Und drei Räder, Triebwerke, die hatten zum Beispiel zwei Haupttriebwerke an Bord. Alles war redundant ausgelegt. Und am Ende kommt man dann, wenn man dann kaufmännisch alles untereinander schreibt und die so mobiliert, dann kommt eine große Zahl raus. Und die muss auf die Rakete passen.
Auf die Rakete, das war dann eine Titan-Rakete. Wo ist er gestartet? Dann Cape Canaveral. Und Start war unproblematisch. Wie lange war er denn unterwegs?
Sieben Jahre. Am 1.07.2004 war die Ankunft, also war das Abbremsmanöver. Die eigentliche Ankunft im Saturn-System war eigentlich schon Wochen vorher. Also das erste Bild, das man jetzt aus relativer Nähe zum Saturn machte, das erste Bild, wo die Kamera sich wirklich zum Saturn drehte und wo man wirklich den Saturn sehr schön sah, das wurde hier gefeiert wie Weihnachten. Also da haben wir uns alle gefreut. Ich weiß noch, ich glaube, das war ganz kurz nach einer, da waren zwei Ereignisse Anfang Juni 2004. Einmal wurde Venus von der Erde aus gesehen über die Sonnenoberfläche, so vor der Sonnenoberfläche vorbei flog, also dass man sie mit so einer Sonnenfinsternis-Bulle sehen konnte, mit einem schwarzen Fleck. Das war ein astronomisches Ereignis. Und dann flog die Cassini-Raumsonde am äußersten Wachhund des Datornensystems, Föbe, vorbei. Föbe ist wahrscheinlich nur ein eingefangener Komet, ein so genannter Centaur. Ist also ein großer Brocken Eis und Gestein, der da rumfliegt und der zum ersten Mal jetzt aus nur einigen, wenigen tausend Kilometer Entfernung beobachtet wurde. Also war das war wirklich praktischen Vorgeschmack auf das, was noch kommen würde. Und da haben uns dann alle die Finger gelegt danach. Das war wirklich bemerkenswert, also wirklich gestochen scharfe Bilder.
Was wurde denn Cassini alles mitgegeben an Instrumenten, um jetzt diesen Saturn auch so umfangreich, wie man sich das nur vorstellen kann, abzuklappern?
Also Cassini selbst hatte einmal, der Schutzschild war auch gleichzeitig ein Messinstrument. Man hatte gemessen, wie viele Teilchen da einschlagen bei den Durchfühlen.
Also der Schutzschild gegen den Ring.
Ja, gegen die Ringteilchen, gegen die Staubteilchen.
Was wusste man denn über den Ring vorher?
Man wusste zumindest, dass er sehr flach ist. Der ist wirklich nur einige hundert Meter dick. Das wusste man. Weil es eben wirklich so ist, dass Teilchen aus der Reihe tanzen. Es ist also ein sehr großer Zwang zur Konformität, kann man sagen. Teilchen aus der Reihe tanzen, die kollidieren sofort mit anderen und werden wieder auf ihre Äquatoria-Bahnen gezwungen. Das sind also Teilchen, die sind von Zigarettenstaub, also was mit dem Zigarettenrauch so hat, ganz mikroskopischen Teilchen, bis hin zu maximalen Teilchen, die so groß sind wie ein Haus, aber davon auch nur wenige. Die meisten Teilchen sind vielleicht nur so Kiesel und die fliegen da alle wie...
Steine, ist das Eis?
Meistens ist es Eis mit Staub.
Also alles so Kometenmaterial, könnte man sagen.
Es kommt von den äußeren Monden, die auch einen großen Eisanteil haben. Jedes von diesen Teilchen ist ein eigener Mond, kann man sagen. Es ist nicht so, dass eine Scheibe sich uniform bewegt wie eine Schallplatte, sondern es ist wirklich ein einzelner, kleiner Mond. Die weite draußen fliegen auch langsamer, genau wie es bei Monden oder Satelliten der Fall ist.
Im Prinzip ist der Saturn nochmal so ein eigenes Sonnensystem mit sich selber. Mit so einer misslungenen Sonne in der Mitte und drum herum so eine Staubscheibe, wie es auch bei der Ausbildung des Sonnensystems mal gewesen sein muss, aber eben viel kleiner.
Das kann man so sagen. Es ist wie eine Aggressionsscheibe, das kann man sagen. Wie die Staubscheibe, die um eine junge Sonne kreist.
Aber das klingt auch dann schon sehr 100 Meter dick. Das ist ja nichts. Es ist wirklich ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz... Das klingt jetzt irgendwie nicht so, als ob man da so mühelos durchfliegen könnte.
Richtig, man ist ja auch nicht durchgeflogen, sondern zum Glück gibt es Zonen, in denen es die Schwerkraft, Einflüsse von Monden gibt, die einige einzelne Gebiete, ganz schmale, aber sehr eng umrissene Gebiete, freiräumen. In dem Gebiet war es halt so, wir sind durch eine Lücke geflogen, die von einem Mond freigeräumt wurde. Es gibt auch weiter aus noch welche, wo man weiter innen, in den Ringen resonante Effekte sieht. Also wenn Teilchen beispielsweise dann zwei Umläufe schaffen, wenn der Mond gerade einen Umlauf geschafft hat, dann würden die ja praktisch immer an der gleichen Stelle ihrer Bahn gestört werden. Und da bleiben sie nicht lange auf der Bahn. Also alle Objekte, die in diesem speziellen Abstand sind vom Saturn, die sind dann irgendwann da weg. Deswegen hat man da eine Lücke.
Sind denn alle Monde des Saturns auch auf dieser Scheibe?
Nein, aber die meisten. Die meisten, einige nicht. Und das sind aber, gerade von dem ich eben gesprochen habe, der Vöbe, der äußerste Mond, dieser Wachhund, der ist ein eingefangener Centaur, also ein eingefangener Komet, und der ist auf einer Retro-Gradbahn, also fliegt verkehrt rum wie ein Geisterfahrer. Und der ist auf einer ganz eigenen, also das sieht man da schon. Aber es ist eben das Erstaunliche, dass die alle da, so wie am Schnürchen, also gerade die innere Monde wie am Schnürchen in der Äquator-Ebene eine fast kreisförmige Bahn ziehen. Das ist schon bemerkenswert.
Und so wie die Planeten im Sonnensystem quasi ihre Bahn freiräumen, so räumen da auch dann die Monde in diesem Ring auf und schaffen einfach Platz für einen Durchflug.
So kann man das sehen, ja.
Und wie groß sind dann diese Abstände im Vergleich?
Na ja, einige... Diese Lücken in den Ringen sind... Kommt darauf an, die Enketeilung ist größer. Das sind vielleicht einige tausend Kilometer. Und da, wo wir durchgeflogen sind, sind es einige hundert Kilometer.
Das reicht dann aber schon als Ziel.
Man muss schon gut zielen. Gut zielen und die Luft anhalten.
Ja, was heißt denn gut zielen? Also wie zielt man denn auf sowas? Das ist ja das Ende einer langen Flugbahn. Inwiefern ist dieses Zielnehmen schon Teil der ursprünglichen Bahnplanung? Oder ist das so eine Last-Minute-Entscheidung vor Ort unter Hernahme der Instrumente? Und dann peilt man nochmal genau und gibt das letzte Kommando für den tatsächlichen Durchflug.
Ja, das ist ein guter Stichpunkt. Also Hernahme der Instrumente ist richtig, denn die ganze Mission, wie sie gemacht wird, hätte nicht gemacht werden können ohne sogenannte optische Navigation. Das heißt, die Kameras, man hat ja eine Kamera an Bord von Cassini. Wir wollten übrigens über die Instrumente noch sprechen. Also die Kamera an Bord von Cassini, die dient nicht nur als wissenschaftliches Instrument, sondern auch als Navigationsinstrument. Die macht Bilder von den Monden vor dem Hintergrund der Sterne. Also man sieht immer Hintergrundsterne. Und dann kann man, dadurch, dass man eben sieht, wo der Mond ist und wo er eigentlich sein müsste, aufgrund der Bahndaten, die man vorher kannte, sieht man, wie gut oder wie schlecht man die Bahn kannte, kann die Voraussage korrigieren. Und genau das hat man auch gemacht. Also ohne diese sogenannte optische Navigation wäre die Mission so gar nicht möglich gewesen. Und Navigation hatte es schon einen Anflug gegeben, da aber vorwiegend auf der Basis von Messdaten von Bodenstationen auf der Erde. Also man misst die Funklaufzeit, man misst die Doppelverschiebung des Signals und kann daraus die Bahn bestimmen. Und aus diesen Messdaten kann man ziemlich genau die Bahn berechnen. Und ziemlich genau heißt, das ist natürlich immer ein sehr, sehr vager Begriff. Das ist leider auch so, ich kann es nicht genau sagen, weil es eben davon abhängt, wie wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel Manöver hat, Triebwerksmanöver, dann machen die die Messgenauigkeit wieder kaputt. Das heißt, man hat so wenig Manöver wie möglich und korrigiert dann eben nur die Bahn so, dass man auch noch genug Zeit hat, um hinterher den Fehler, das Manövers wieder rauszurechnen. Und so kann man eben, also die 100 Kilometer Zielgenauigkeit ist kein Problem auf die Entfernung.
Aber so die Kommunikation dürfte ja recht schleppend laufen, wenn das Ding schon kurz vorm Saturn ist. Was für eine Funklaufzeit hat man da?
Ja, da hat man so größtendeutige Stunde.
Eine Stunde? Das heißt, man kriegt irgendwelche Daten eine Stunde zu spät, kann da eine Stunde drüber nachdenken und schickt es nochmal über eine Stunde hin. Und das muss halt alles mit eingepreist werden bei den neuen Kommandanten.
Ja, das ist so. Das weiß man aber vorher. Also mal eben schnell reagieren, das geht nicht. Das ist klar. Und alles wussten wir auch bei der Huygens-Landung. Also alles, was passieren sollte, selbst als wir die Funksigale empfangen haben, wir wussten ja, und zwar immer bewusst, dass was da passiert ist, das ist schon von einer Stunde passiert.
Das ist die Vergangenheit. Ja, so wie man sich das Licht von millionenalten Sternen anschaut, hat man auch an der Stelle einfach die natürliche Verzögerung.
Zurück zu den Instrumenten.
Also gab es nur eine oder gab es mehrere?
Die Kamera besteht aus zwei, aus einer sogenannten Teleskopkamera. Die hat ein sehr enges Blickfeld. Also es ist ein wirkliches Teleskop und deswegen ist es auch groß. Die Optik ist da sehr schwer, das Glas ist schwer. Und eine Weitwinkelkamera, obwohl die eigentlich auch noch ein relativ enges Blickfeld hatte, aber die hatte ein dreieinhalb Grad Blickfeld und die Teleskopkamera ein Zehntel davon. Und die CCDs von dieser Kamera, das ist ganz interessant, wenn man das vergleicht mit Handykameras oder dem, was heute so ein billiges Handy hat, das waren 1 Megapixel.
Das reicht.
Naja, das war halt Technik der frühen 90er. Und Bilder, also wenn man Fahrtbilder macht, dann läuft das so, dass man da eben Filter vorschiebt. Also das ist ein schwarz-weiß CCD. Und dann macht man einen roten Filter davor, Bild, blauer Filter davor, Bild, grüner Filter davor, Bild und dann noch einmal ohne Filter, um die Helligkeit, um die Luminanz zu messen. Und daraus, auf der Erde werden dann Bilder zusammen gerechnet. Das heißt, sie können ja auf der Cassini-Webseite, die Amerikaner sind ja immer sehr schnell damit, die tun die sogenannten Rohbilder rein. Und das sind aber immer die Bilder aus dem schwarz-weiß-Kander. Ja, man kann zumindest, das ist so ein Teaser sozusagen. Aber Farbe, das muss berechnet werden. Das ist ja kalibriert, das ist ein kalibrierter Farb. Okay, das ist also das optische System, das sogenannte ISS.
Also es gab zwei Kameras.
Ja, die gehören zum Imaging Subsystem. Dann Spektrometer sind immer sehr wichtig, wenn man über Spektrometer basieren darf, dass man die ausgesandte elektromagnetische Strahlung, jetzt nicht nur Licht, sondern auch UV-Strahlung, Infrarotstrahlung, die man von irgendwoher empfängt, in einem Prisma zerlegt und dann feststellt, okay, habe ich jetzt ein kontinuierliches Spektrum da drin oder sehe ich da Lücken drin? Bei bestimmten Frequenzen, wenn ich eine Lücke in einer Frequenz habe, dann kann ich eine Tabelle nachschauen. Okay, wenn ich jetzt also das habe, zum Beispiel Methan, dann müsste ich bei der und der Frequenz eine Lücke haben. Okay, habe ich die? Ja, okay, da muss also Methan drin sein.
Also das ist diese Absorptionslinie.
Absorptionslinien, ja. Ich wollte das komplizierte Wort vermeiden.
Nee, wir müssen gar nichts vermeiden.
Ja, also Absorptionslinien, die kann man aus der Spektroskopie, kann man aus großer Entfernung feststellen, was für Stoffe es in weit entfernten Objekten gibt. Und so wissen wir, im Prinzip wissen wir, aus was für Materialien Sterne zusammengesetzt sind. Das wissen wir schon seit über 100 Jahren. Und das ist ein sehr wichtiges Werkzeug der Astronomen. Dann gibt es ein Magnetometer.
Also das Spektrometer war einfach dazu da, um einfach bei den beobachteten Objekten, vor allem natürlich dann Saturn und Titan, genau hinzuschauen, was ist da jetzt wirklich drin, um einfach einen genaueren Blick zu haben, als man den jetzt von der Erde aushärt.
Ja, bei Titan auch, bei den anderen Monen. Also das Licht, was von der Oberfläche reflektiert wird. Übrigens gibt es nicht nur, um das komplizierter wiederzumachen, es gibt nicht nur Spektrometer, die jetzt einfach nur einen Lichtstrahl analysieren, sondern es gibt auch sogenannte abbildende Spektrometer. Da kann man also praktisch sehen, okay, ich habe jetzt hier eine Karte von dem Körper und oben habe ich mehr Eis und unten habe ich offensichtlich mehr Gestein und rechts habe ich ein bisschen mehr von was anderem. Also es ist praktisch eine Karte von dem Objekt, das ich sehe, wo aber die Farben, die ich da habe, nicht die wirklichen Farben wiedergeben, die ich sehe, sondern die chemische Zusammensetzung.
Um einfach so ein Gesamtbild zu bekommen, was hier wohl vorherrscht an welcher Stelle.
Genau, weil es ja wichtig ist, nicht nur auf dem Mond gibt es das, sondern auf dem Mond gibt es dort das und dort was anderes. Und eben die Spektrometer sind nicht nur im sichtbaren Bereich, sondern im nahen Infrarotbereich und im ultravioletten Bereich. Das ist wichtig, dass man eben wirklich auch andere Wellenlängen zur Verfügung hat.
Das heißt, sie kamen dann auch zum ersten Mal zum Einsatz schon, also Venus wissen wir jetzt nicht, aber das wurde alles dann auch schon auf den Jupiter ausgerichtet. Man hat jetzt da schon die volle Instrumentarik eingesetzt?
Nein, auf dem Mond hat man auch schon sowas. Also beim Vorbeiflug. Der Erde hat uns auf den Mond ausgerichtet und das war auch wichtig, weil du hast ja gehört, dass am Mond Wasser entdeckt wurde von einer indischen Sonde, Chandrayaan. Und zwar Wasser, das wahrscheinlich sehr fein verteilt überall an der Oberfläche vorhanden ist. Und das wahrscheinlich, das weiß man nicht genau, man nimmt an, dass es zu tun hat mit Sonnenwind, der eingelagert wurde. Also Helium-Protonen, die in Wasserstoff umgewandt wurden. Und dann mit Sauerstoff, das freigesetzt wurde durch kosmische Strahlung, denn zu Hydroxyl wurden, also zu OH, Wasserstoff, Sauerstoff. Und dann, also man hat auf jeden Fall das festgestellt, und man nimmt auch an, dass es Wasser gibt. Und das wurde zum Teil auch durch Cassini-Messungen bestätigt.
Also das Auffinden von richtigem Wasser.
Es war eigentlich nur Kalibration des Instruments, weil der Mond ist ein Mond, und da will man schon mal ausprobieren, was das Instrument so hergibt, obwohl es dafür eigentlich nicht gebaut war.
Also man hat sozusagen sowohl bestätigt das, was die andere Sonde gesehen hat, als auch sich selber bestätigt, dass die eigenen Instrumente funktionieren.
So ist es. Also es ist immer wichtig, dass verschiedene Sonden unabhängige Messungen liefern.
Hätte man jetzt zu dem Zeitpunkt festgestellt, dass irgendwas nicht richtig funktioniert, hätte man durch Kalibration die Möglichkeit gehabt, das auszugleichen?
Ja, also in gewissen Rahmen immer. Also Instrumente müssen immer kalibriert werden. Und man lernt natürlich immer dazu. Also man kann tatsächlich auch noch Fehler in Instrumenten später ausgleichen, dadurch, dass man weiß, dass es sie gibt.
Aber dazu muss man halt erstmal auf irgendwas ausrichten, was man eben auch schon vorher weiß.
Das Wesen einer Kalibration besteht darin, dass man eben mit bekannten, bekanntes Muster abgleicht. Und ein weiteres ist zumindest der Cosmic Dust Analyzer. Und der ist deswegen besonders interessant für uns aus Deutschland, weil der von einem Team aus Deutschland federführend entwickelt wurde. Und die sind auch bei anderen Raumsonnen dabei. Also die sind ganz groß drin. Und die saßen damals noch in Heidelberg und die sind, glaube ich, jetzt umgezogen nach Stuttgart. Aber das sind also Wissenschaftler, die vom Max-Pank-Institut für Kernphysik. Und dieser Cosmic Dust Analyzer, das ist wichtig, weil man Staub, der da rumfliegt, chemisch analysieren kann. Also man fängt den ein und der trifft auf eine Oberfläche und die Energie ist so, dass er sofort zu Plasma verdampft. Also zu Plasma wird, also so heiß, dass er nicht mehr verdampft. Das Plasma ist das, was passiert, wenn man Stoff richtig heiß macht. Also wirklich ganz heiß, dass selbst die Elektronen aus der Hülle wachsen. Und dann kann man feststellen, was für chemische Elemente in diesen Staubkörnchen drin waren. Dadurch, dass dieses Plasma zwischen zwei Elektronen fliegt. Das trifft auf eine Oberfläche und das Plasma wird dann reflektiert und auf seinem Flug misst man die Laufzeit zwischen zwei Elektroden. Es löst also immer ein elektrisches Signal aus. Wenn es an einer Elektrode vorbei fliegt, dann an eine andere Elektrode. Aus dieser Laufzeit kann man genau messen, dass muss die und die Masse gehabt haben. Und aus der Atommasse kann man eben feststellen, ok, Tabelle nachschauen, das muss jetzt Silizium gewesen sein, oder Eisen oder Aluminium oder so. Das ist ein ganz wichtiges Werkzeug, das die Astronomen haben, um festzustellen, woraus besteht das ganze Zeug, was da oben ist.
Das war das, was auf diesem Hitzeschild angebracht war?
Nein, das war auf dem Hitzeschild. Da war einfach so eine Art Detektor, der Mars zählte einfach nur. Ok, jetzt trifft was ein, jetzt trifft noch was ein. Und das haben sie hinterher abgespielt, das war ganz interessant. Das war wie so ein Timpanero, so ein südamerikanischer Trommler und dann noch mal hundertmal beschleunigt. Also wirklich, da war Rhythmus drin, das war richtig Beat drin. Das CDA, dieses Cosmic Dust Analyzer, ist ein eigenständiges Instrument. Das ist wie so eine Dose, die vorne offen ist und wo hinten diese Folie ist, wo die Staubteilchen auftreffen. Also wahrscheinlich liegen jetzt gerade, wenn Wissenschaftler sich das anhören, die damit beteiligt sind, die kenne ich auch persönlich, die legen wahrscheinlich gerade, denen rollen sich da die Zähnegel hoch, wenn ich das so amateurhaft erkläre. Aber es ist wirklich so, dass man damit die chemische Zusammensetzung des Staubs analysieren kann. Und eben nicht nur sehen kann, da ist jetzt was aufgetreten, sondern was ist da aufgetreten? Was ist da eben aufgeschlagen? Was ist da drin? Und wichtig ist das nicht nur wegen Titan, wenn ich jetzt einen kleinen Exkurs mir erlauben, sondern weil man einen anderen Mond hat, Enceladus, der ist weiter drin. Und in dem Mond hat man mit einer Kamera festgestellt, Mensch, das sind Fontänen. Da ist wirklich sowas wie Geysire. Und man hat das gesehen, als man im Gegenlicht diesen Mond fotografiert hat, bei einem Nahen vorbeifflug, da hat man wirklich gesehen, da kommen so Geysire hoch. Also wirklich Wasserdampf. Wasserdampf und Eis, das sind sofort gefriert, konnte man im Gegenlicht sehen. Ein sehr schönes Bild. Es war so blau hinterlegt durch die Brechung des Lichts. Und das bedeutet, dass unter der Oberfläche von diesem Enceladus wirklich flüssiges Wasser sein muss. Und bei flüssigem Wasser, da horchen sofort alle Wissenschaftler auf. Flüssiges Wasser, das ist so ungefähr der Heilige Gral bei der Suche nach...
Das wusste man vorher noch nicht.
Das wusste man nicht, keine Ahnung.
Aber wenn das Wasser von Themen sind, hätte man das nicht durch Beobachtung von der Erde aus auch feststellen müssen?
Von der Erde aus guckt man in die falsche Richtung. Da guckt man ja immer weg von der Sonne. Also man hat das gesehen dadurch, dass man hin zur Sonne guckte. Da hat man es gesehen.
Sterne haben da nicht ausgereicht.
Man muss es natürlich erst mal wissen. Und hier hat man eben, wenn man dicht dran ist, dann auch noch die große Leuchtkraft der Sonne, die ist ja noch relativ, also verglichen mit Sternen, um viele, viele Größenordnungen höher. Da hat man es gesehen. Und mit diesem Cosmic Dust Analyzer konnte man beim folgenden Vorbeiflug feststellen, was da drin ist. Und da hat man festgestellt, dass das eben nicht nur Eis ist, sondern dass da noch Silikate drin sind. Das heißt, dass der Kern dieses Mondes, also 500 Kilometer groß, dass der felsig sein muss. Und dass über diesem Kern offensichtlich ein flüssiger Ozean ist. In diesem ganzen Eis ist irgendwo mindestens noch eine große Tasche aus flüssigem Wasser. Und der Mond wird durch gezeigten Kräfte durchgeknetet wahrscheinlich und irgendwann, wie wenn ich zum Beispiel, wenn ich irgendwas, wo eine Flüssigkeit drin ist, zu fest drücke, dann spritze es durch einen Riss raus. Und genau das ist da passiert.
Das passiert da am laufenden Meter?
Das passiert da öfter anscheinend, ja. Also es muss offensichtlich einen großen Vorrat geben an flüssigem Wasser im Inneren dieses Mondes. Also flüssiges Wasser ist wirklich eine wichtige Sache, weil flüssiges Wasser ist eine der Vorausbedingungen, das ist jetzt immer ein großes Wort, aber für Leben, wie wir es kennen, ist flüssiges Wasser eine unabdingbare Voraussetzung.
Das heißt, eigentlich war man auf den Titan scharf und dann ist man auf den Enceladus gestoßen und war schon total überrascht.
Ja, das nennt man auch wieder so denglish Serendipity, also eine völlig unerwartete Entdeckung. Das sind immer die wichtigsten Entdeckungen, wenn ich es vorher schon weiß, dann brauch ich eigentlich nicht hinzufliegen. Aber wenn man irgendwo hinfliegt, dann weiß man meistens mehr, man weiß, was man vorher gedacht hat, ist falsch. Einiges von dem, was man vorher gedacht hat, ist halb richtig, aber doch ein bisschen anders. Und eine ganze Menge, was man vorher überhaupt nicht erwartet hatte, ist auf einmal aufgetreten und man hat keine Erklärung dafür. Und das sind die wichtigsten Sachen, weil man dann nämlich rausfinden muss, warum ist denn das so?
Wenn man sich so die Bilder von dem Enceladus anschaut, dann sieht das ja schon so aus, als ob da irgendwie Wasser durch Kanäle fließt oder durch Flüsse fließt.
Ja, das Wasser ist an der Oberfläche. Der Enceladus hat ja keine Atmosphäre. Also an der Oberfläche kann eigentlich nichts sein. Aber es muss irgendwelche Risse geben, wie Gläscherspalten von unten, wo es hochgedrückt wird.
Ah, okay, das heißt, es sind einfach nur so die Auslassstellen am Ende, da wo der aufbricht.
Die wissen auch, wo das ist. Das ist in Polen näher. Also es sind wirklich... Also der Enceladus, wenn man den so sieht, ist das wie eine Billardkugel. Aber offensichtlich ist es eben doch ein zerkratzer Billardkugel und einige von diesen Kratzern gehen ziemlich tief.
Das heißt, haben wir jetzt eigentlich alle Instrumente zusammen. Wir haben vom Imaging-Subsystem gesprochen, also der Teleskopkamera, der Weitwinkelkamera, die halt Farbbilder machen können, wenn man sich entsprechend ausrechnet aus verschiedenen Teilbildern. Das Spektrometer, was halt sehr genau die Zusammensetzung in bestimmten Frequenzbereichen bestimmen kann. Diesen Cosmic Dust Analyzer, der also über diesen Plasma trägt die genaue Zusammensetzung, dessen was aufschlägt, mitzählt. Und dann zusätzlich noch, wie heißt der eigentlich, dieser Detektor auf dem Hitzeschild, der einfach nur mitzählt, der Trommelzähler, hat auch noch irgendeinen spacigen Namen.
Bestimmt, der ist gerade entfallen da.
Und das sind jetzt so die wesentlichen Instrumente gewesen?
Ne, dieses Magnetometer sollte man auch erwähnen. Also Magnetometer ist gerade in dem Körper mit einem starken Magnetfeld sehr wichtig. Und beim Saturn ist es so, dass das Magnetfeld, dass die Ausrichtung des Magnetfelds eigentlich unerklärlich ist. Also wir wissen nicht, warum das jetzt so ausgewirkt ist, wie es ist. Ich weiß nicht, ob das inzwischen einer rausgekriegt hat.
Was ist denn mit dem Magnetfeld?
Also man würde eigentlich erwarten, dass das, die Neigung ist nicht so, wie man es erwartet. Also es ist jetzt wirklich nicht mein Fachgebiet, aber ich weiß noch, dass da die Wissenschaftler sehr aufgeregt waren deswegen. Für mich war das Magnetometer deswegen wichtig, weil es für mich, also ich bin ja eigentlich mehr, ich bin ja ESA, ein ESA-Mensch. Und für mich interessiert natürlich den Huygens. Cassini interessiert mich natürlich so, wie es jeden, der überhaupt in diesem, in dieser Homsun interessiert ist, interessieren würde. Aber Cassini interessiert mich in erster Linie in seiner Rolle als Mutterschiff für mein Baby, Huygens. Und das Magnetometer wurde verwendet, kann man auch sagen vergewaltigt, als Messinstrument für Huygens. Denn Huygens, wie alle Raumsonden, also wie alle Raumsonden, wo Metalle drin sind, hat es auch ein gewisses Magnetfeld. Ja, und Cassini auch. Deswegen muss das Magnetometer an einem langen Auslieger liegen, damit es von der Sonne nicht so gestört wird. Und als Huygens ausgesetzt wurde, da wurden Sprengbolzen gezündet und Federn schoben das weg und versetzen es gleichzeitig in Drehung. Und wir wussten jetzt nicht, wie diese Federn sich da gehalten haben über die sieben Jahre Flug in ganz verschiedenen Temperaturen. Und dadurch, dass das Magnetometer genau das Magnetfeld der eisenhaltigen Metalle in Huygens messen konnte, man konnte tatsächlich in den Messdaten vom Magnetometer sehen, wie so eine Wellenfunktion allein durch die Störung durch Huygens, als er sich von Cassini entfernte, auftrat. Die Sonde drehte sich und flog dabei. Huygens drehte sich und flog dabei von Cassini weg. Und man konnte in den Magnetometer-Messdaten so eine Fluktuation sehen. Und aus der Fluktuation konnten wir sehen, dass Cassini sich mit mehr als fünf Umdrehungen pro Minute, das also nominale Wert war, alles drüber hinaus, war besser als wir wollten, mindestens fünf Umdrehungen pro Minute. Und wir konnten sehen, dass es also wirklich gegeben war. Wir hatten glaube ich sogar siebeneinhalb. Also das Huygens sich schneller drehte als wir es mindestens brauchten, damit er stabil seine Lage halten würde. Und da ging ein großes Aufatmen und Schweiß von der Stirn wischen um mich den Raum. Und das war für mich also mein persönliches Danke Magnetometer-Moment.
Wusste man das auch schon? Ich meine, sind das so Sachen, die man wirklich auch von Anfang an schon so plant?
Nö. Das war also rein serendipit. Das war wirklich hinterher, wo wir wussten, also wirklich Glück.
Das heißt erst nach der Loslösung ist man auf die Idee gekommen, sich diese Daten anzuschauen?
Nee, kurz vorher hatten wir uns schon gedacht, Mensch, da sollte man doch mal reinschauen. Das war so einer der Momente, wo man sich sagt, Mensch, man könnte doch mal, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, Anführungsstriche zu.
Passiert das häufig?
Passiert dauernd, ja.
Während der Mission?
Ja, also bei jeder Mission, dass da Leute zusammensitzen und sagen, Mensch, man könnte doch mal und die anderen sagen, Ja, hast eigentlich recht, das sollte man machen. Und das ist das Wichtigste. Also man kann, das Feld ist so weit. Und manchmal ist es sogar so, dass ein ganz Fachfremder einem sagt, Ey, hört mal, wir haben doch damals schon das und das gemacht. Und da hab ich mir jetzt gestern beim Duschen überlegt, das könnte man doch hier auch machen. Da hab ich immer meine besten Ideen unter der Dusche. Und dann ist die erste Reaktion, ach, was weißt du schon? Und dann beim Essen überlegt man sich, Mensch, Moment mal, doch eigentlich recht. Und dann sitzt man nochmal zusammen und dann überlegt man sich und dann wird daraus was. Und so läuft Wissenschaft. Wissenschaft ist nicht immer planbar, die Ergebnisse sind nicht immer planbar. Und vieles in der Wissenschaft kommt eben dadurch, dass da Leute zusammensitzen und jeder seine Erfahrungen einbringt und dass man sich was überlegt. Wahrscheinlich, wenn da nicht so richtig Leute zusammensitzen, wird auch was vergessen. Also ich möchte gar nicht wissen, was wir alles so vergessen haben, was wir eigentlich hätten machen können.
Jetzt haben wir viel über Cassini gesprochen und immer nur so nebenbei erwähnt. Na ja, da ist dann auch noch dieses Huygens. Also wir haben es ja schon erwähnt, da hängt an der eigentlichen Raumsonde Cassini noch eine zweite Sonde dran, deren eigentliches Ziel ist, auf den Titan abgesetzt zu werden. Diesen Mond, den man eben von vornherein schon im Blick gehabt hat. Als man noch nicht wusste, dass auch vielleicht Enceladus auch noch ein wertvolles Ziel gewesen wäre. Da hätte man dann wahrscheinlich am liebsten auch gleich noch was hingeworfen, oder?
Ohne Atmosphäre wäre es natürlich schlecht im Fallschirm. Da wird ja nicht so viel bringen. Das ist auch das Problem, da müssten wir alles mit Triebwerken machen. Also das wäre eine eigene Mission gewesen.
Aber da stand ja auch nichts zu einer Debatte. Aber hier hat man sich eigentlich ein Objekt vorgenommen, was, ich weiß nicht, erdähnlich wäre jetzt wahrscheinlich ein bisschen vermessen. Aber es hat ja nicht so viel wirklich so eine Atmosphäre in unserem Sonnensystem.
Also erdähnlich ist gar nicht vermessen. Ich denke, die Parallelen zur Erde sind sehr stark. Das ist ein Titan, das ist eine Welt, die erdähnlicher ist als der Mars. In vieler Hinsicht. Eben durch die dichte Atmosphäre. Aber eben auch ganz anders als die Erde, weil das, was auf der Erde das Wasser macht, das macht auf dem Titan Methan. Also es gibt Methanregen, es gibt Methanflüsse, es gibt Methanseen, es gibt Methansümpfe, es gibt Methanerosionen. Es gibt wahrscheinlich sogar Karstregionen, Karstregionen, wo unterirdische Erosionen stattfinden und dann von oben alles einstürzt, wie in den Jugoslawien, in diesen Kalksteingebirgen. Dann gibt es auf dem Titan das, was bei uns das Gestein macht, das macht auf dem Titan weder das Eis, also alles ist irgendwie so wie auf der Erde, aber irgendwie ganz anders. Das ist so interessant an diesem Körper.
Das wusste man schon vorher? Oder das ist ein Ergebnis?
Das ist ein Ergebnis von Huygens sogar, denn Huygens hat festgestellt, dass es ein Gas in der Atmosphäre gibt, in ganz geringen Konzentrationen, das eigentlich nur erklärbar ist durch den Zerfall von radioaktiven Materialien in Silikarten. Und wie kommt dieses Gas, also wie kommt dieses Zerfallsprodukt in die Atmosphäre, wenn doch hunderte von Kilometern Eis über dem Silikatkern liegen? Die einzige Erklärung ist über Kryovulkanismus, dass es also Vulkane gibt, die aus großen Tiefen gespeist werden, also in dem Inneren hat man einen relativ warmen Kern, der erwärmt wird durch radioaktiven Zerfall, wie auch bei der Erde. Das ist ja auch so. Und dieses Zerfallsprodukt steigt auf und also dieses Gas steigt auf und kann aber das Eis nicht durchdringen, aber es kann in Wasser eingelagert werden, wenn es flüssige Zonen gibt und wenn es Kryovulkanismus gibt, wo also ein Vulkan tatsächlich aus Eis aufgewölbt ist und Wasser speit, so wie auf der Erde Vulkane eben mit Erde und mit Gestein aufgewölbt sind und flüssiges Gestein speien, dann kann dieses Gas in die Atmosphäre gelangen. Also das ist eine ganz spannende Sache. Spannend ist ein sehr überstauberzieheter Begriff. Das war wirklich so. Der weiß ja darauf hin, dass es eben nicht nur einen warmen Kern gibt, einen Gesteinskern, das man eigentlich schon wusste, sondern der weiß auch darauf hin, dass es eben ein Kyro-Volkanismus und deswegen auch irgendwo flüssiges Wasser geben muss.
Bevor wir nochmal auf den Titan genauer kommen und was jetzt die Ergebnisse waren bei Huygens, vielleicht nochmal kurz zu Huygens selber. Also das Ding ist ja separat entwickelt worden. Wer hat ihn gebaut?
Der wurde größtenteils, also die europäische Industrie hat ihn gebaut und Instrumente wurden beigetragen, also wissenschaftliche Instrumente wurden beigetragen von amerikanischen Instituten, von deutschen Stellen, von europäischen Forschungsinstituten, also von Leuten überall.
Und was war da jetzt drin?
In Huygens war wieder eine sehr, da war praktisch alle Tastszenne, die wir auch haben, waren da drin. Also zum Gucken war eine Kamera drin. Das war eine Kamera, die selbst die billigste Webcam kann das besser, aber das war eben die Technologie, die man hatte und die man über diese geringe Datenbandbreite übertragen konnte. Also selbst die Datenbandbreite, da würde jeder Modem-Benutzer die Nase rumpfen, aber das war eben das, was man hatte. Die Daten wurden übertragen über Cassini und von Cassini dann gespeichert und später zur Erde zurückgeschickt.
Und vor allem, es war klar, dass Huygens das ja nicht überleben wird, diesen Aufprall. Das heißt, man hatte eigentlich nur diesen Moment des Abwurfs und alle Daten, die gewonnen werden konnten, mussten dann auch in diesem Zeitraum übertragen werden.
Ja, also die Zeitschiene war so. Cassini warf Huygens ab, setzte Huygens ab am 25. Dezember 2004 um, ich glaube, es war noch sehr früh morgens. Und wir waren dann alle hier. Kleine Anekdote am Rande, wir haben dann bei den Amerikanern angerufen, die haben das ja gemacht und die haben gesagt, was macht ihr? Und wir haben gesagt, wir trinken hier Whisky, ein bisschen nicht gebracht. Und die haben gefragt, was, ihr dürft Alkohol trinken? Und wir haben gefragt, was, ihr dürft kein Alkohol trinken? Aber das war wirklich, ich meine...
War das zur Beruhigung oder was?
Wir trinken nicht oft, aber da musste es einfach mal sein.
Jetzt nur zur Beruhigung oder als Feier?
Wir mussten einfach mal aus der Sicht der Ja.
Was ist denn in welchem Zustand man sich da befindet?
Im Zustand der absoluten Gelösteinheit. Also es war wirklich, wir wussten, alles was wir machen konnten, war gemacht. Jetzt können wir nur noch abwarten, denn die Sonde war ja nicht, die Sonde war ja nicht kommandierbar mehr. Man konnte nur noch Kommandos schicken über die sogenannte Nabelschnur und die war in dem Moment der Abtrennung getrennt.
Das heißt, die Kommandos eigentlich waren bereits gegeben. Man wartete jetzt nur noch auf das Resultat.
Die konnten nur noch ausführen jetzt.
Wann wurden die Kommandos gegeben?
Die wurden in der Vorbereitung gegeben.
Also schon Tage, Wochen vorher.
Also die wurden über Cassini gegeben, über die Nabelschnur, an dem Boardcomputer, im Boardcomputer von Huygens gespeichert und blieben dann da. Und die Sequenz der Ausführung war festgelegt. Und dann flog das praktisch vom 25. Dezember bis zum 14. April 2005, dem Eintritt, flog sie autonom und flog, also eine große Strecke natürlich, und Cassini flog eine etwas andere Bahn und machte noch Manöver, um sich selbst praktisch aus dem Eintrittsbahn zu nehmen. Denn in dem Moment des Aussetzens waren ja beide Raumsonden auf einem Kollisionskurs mit Titanen. Cassini musste sich selbst aus der Schussrichtung manövrieren und musste sich so manövrieren, dass er hinterher so am Titanen vorbeifliegen würde, dass er die Daten von Huygens empfangen konnte. Das war ganz wichtig, ja.
Also nicht nur selber in Sicherheit bringen, sondern auch so in Sicherheit bringen, dass die Kommunikation nicht abreißt.
Jaja, also das ist eben einer der Gründe, warum man Missionsanalytiker braucht. Also ganz einfach ist es nicht. Und von dahin war Huygens auf sich selbst gestellt. Die Sondes schalteten sich automatisch ein in dem Moment, wo die, also schon vorher, durch eine Zeitschaltuhr gesteuert. Und die Instrumente schalteten sich ein in dem Moment, wo die Abbrems-, die Accelerationssensoren, also die Bremssensoren, die merkten, oh jetzt werde ich ja abgebremst, durch die Atmosphäre feststellten, dass der Eintritt unmittelbar bevorstand. Und alles andere lief eventgesteuert, also Ereignis gesteuert und zeitgesteuert ab.
Wie weit war die Sonde entfernt, als sie abgesetzt wurde? Und wann begann wirklich die Atmosphäre?
Die Sonde war Millionen Kilometer entfernt. Also wir waren, Cassini war ja auf einer Bahn, um den Titanen, die noch weit herausführte, noch bis zu einem, noch weit jenseits der Titanenbahn, war auf einer Bahn um den Saturn, die weit jenseits der Titanenbahn herausführte und setzte auf dieser Ellipsenbahn, also nicht etwa jetzt im direkten Anflug auf den Titanen, die Sonde aus, sondern weit vorher schon. Und beide folgten einer ganz ähnlichen Bahn, also auch dieser weiten Ellipsenbahn und flogenden, auf dem es dann wieder in Richtung Saturn ging, war eben Huygens so gezielt, dass sie den Titanen traf. Und Cassini war durch seine Korrektionsmanöver so gezielt, dass er dem Titanen verfehlte.
Wie genau muss man denn, ich meine, wir fliegen ja hier zu einem Objekt, das will man überhaupt erst mal erforschen. Und alles, was man weiß, ist das, was man aus der Ferne geschaut hat. Wie genau kann man denn die Masse und damit eben auch diese ganzen Bahnen, die man fliegen muss, vorberechnen und wie viel wurde das noch vor Ort durch Messungen ergänzt?
Also was man genau brauchte, war die Masse des Saturn und die kannte man recht gut dadurch, dass man ja die Bahnen der Monde auf dem Teleskop schon von der Erde beobachten kann. Die Masse des Titanen war lange Zeit falsch berechnet worden, weil man eben nicht wusste, wie dick die Atmosphäre wirklich ist. Und man dachte eben, weil die Atmosphäre wirklich dick ist, also wirklich über 1000 km dichte Atmosphäre, dachte man, dass der Titan der größte Mond des Sonnensystems ist. Und dann hat man festgestellt durch diese Messungen mit Sternenverdeckungen, dass die Atmosphäre eben dicker ist als man angenommen hat und musste den Titan in den zweiten Rang zurückversetzen. Der Ganymede vom Jupiter ist ein bisschen größer. Also Titan ist mit 5150 Kilometern aber immer noch ziemlich groß. Also die Störung durch...
Aber das wusste man jetzt auch schon vorher.
Das wusste man schon vorher. Man wusste natürlich mit der Masse nicht so genau, weil man ja zwar weiß, wie groß ist, man weiß aber nicht, wie groß jetzt wieder sich im Inneren zusammensetzt. Das war natürlich ein Störfaktor, dass man eine Unsicherheit hatte. Und ein größerer Störfaktor war, dass sowohl. Huygens als auch Cassini auf diesem weiten Ellipsenbogen, bevor sie den Titan trafen, relativ nahe an einem anderen Mond vorbeiflogen, dem Iapetus. Dieser Mond, dessen Masse war auch nicht ganz genau, da war eine Unsicherheit drin. Und die Störung hätte die Berechnung so versauen können, dass die Zielgenauigkeit reduziert wird. Und da musste man tatsächlich noch die Zielbahn etwas verändern, damit der doch nicht so dicht an dem Iapetus vorbeifliegt und dass die Störung und der unbekannte Graderstörung minimiert wird. Das war noch Kopfzerbrechen, das wir da noch hatten.
Das heißt, Cassini hat vorher auch diese anderen Monde alle noch so weit sensorisch aufgenommen, dass man eben auch all diese Daten dann vor Ort bilden konnte, um dann die finale Bahn zu berechnen.
Nein, Cassini hat mit der Kamera die Positionen der Monde verbessert, die Kenntnis der Position der Monde, aber die Masse des Mondes, ja, Peter, konnte man dadurch nicht bestimmen. Die kann man durch eine sehr enge Vorbeiflüge bestimmen und zu dem Zeitpunkt hat man die Daten noch nicht. Beim Huygens kommt dann noch dazu, dass man das Problem hatte, das sogenannte Huygens-Problem, das entdeckt wurde auf dem Flug zwischen Jupiter und Saturn. Da wurde festgestellt, dass es einen Konstruktionsfehler gab. Beim Empfänger, also es sind eigentlich zwei Bauteile, einmal hat man einen Sender bei Huygens und man hat den Empfänger auf dem Cassini, denn Cassini wirkt ja als Datenrelay. Die Sendeleistung reicht nicht aus, von Huygens direkt zu Erde zu sind. Und der Doppelleffekt ist bekannt, bekannt voraus ist es eben, wenn ein Körper sich auf mich zubewegt, dann höre ich den, dann scheine ich Frequenzen höher wahrzunehmen als sie in Wirklichkeit sind.
Weil sie halt gestaucht werden.
Genau, weil sie gestaucht werden und wenn er sich weg bewegt, scheine ich sie niedriger wahrzunehmen. So und wenn jetzt der Huygens in die Atmosphäre eintritt, wird er gebremst und der Cassini fliegt ungebremst vorbei, das heißt relativ zwischen den beiden habe ich eine Annäherung und dadurch habe ich einen Doppelleffekt und man hat vergessen den zu spezifizieren und in die Berechnung, also in die Auslegung des Empfängers einzubeziehen.
Gab es jetzt einen Grund, dass man das jetzt genau zwischen dem Flug von Jupiter zu Saturn gemerkt hat?
Ja, Schwein gehabt.
Oder war das nur der Zeitpunkt, an dem man es gemerkt hat?
Da hat man es gemerkt, weil man einen Test gemacht hat und eigentlich sollte der Test, also eigentlich hatte man gesagt, den Test brauchen wir nicht auch zu machen, es war spät am Tag und die Leute wollten nach Hause, aber es hat einen Ingenieur, ein hartnäckiger Ingenieur, der hier beim ESOC arbeitete, der jetzt pensioniert ist, der hat gesagt, nee, nee, Leute, das machen wir jetzt noch, also das wollen wir jetzt sehen, wir wollen alles durchtesten und der hat aufgestanden und als dann hinterher, also da hat der Test wurde so durchgeführt, dass man von der Erde ein Signal sendete zum Cassini, dass genau dieses Signal von dem Huygens simulierte, genau die Frequenz und genau die Sendestärke Wir haben hier eine Stärke und mit Daten drin, also mit Dummy-Daten drin und der Cassini sollte dann diese Daten empfangen, dieses Signal empfangen und sollte die Daten speichern und dann zurück zur Erde schicken und dann wollten wir gucken, okay, ist da jetzt drin, was wir hochgeschickt haben. Und als es zurück kam, stellten wir fest, da ist ja nur Müll drin. Also der Cassini konnte diese Daten nicht mit der Empfänger, dieser S-Band-Empfänger, für die bestimmte Frequenz, konnte diese Daten so nicht lesen, weil der eben etwas auf eine falsche Frequenz eingestellt war. So ungefähr, als wenn ich mein Radio, also ein UKW-Radio, auf die falsche Frequenz einstelle, dann kann ich auch nur Rauschen hören und ab und zu mal ein Tonmusik, aber ich kann nicht erkennen, was ist denn.
Kurz bevor der Sender gut klingt oder so.
Ja, so ungefähr. Und das hat man halt festgestellt. Zum Glück war das eben noch so weit vom Saturn entfernt, dass man ein Workaround finden konnte. Also das einfachste wäre gewesen, den Empfänger natürlich umzuprogrammieren, dass er auf eine andere Frequenz, auf der richtigen Frequenz arbeitet. Aber das ging nicht, weil man das hard codiert hat. Und das ist dann praktisch so, als würde man den Außenspiegel vom LKW festschweißen und müsste durch rangieren das LKW jetzt das Objekt, das man sehen will, im Rückspiegel.
Hat man das in Software gemacht oder hat man das dann in der Flugbahn von Cassini?
Mit Software konnte man nichts machen, das musste man wirklich die Flugbahn von Huygens und der Eintrittspunkt in die Atmosphäre auf den Titanen musste man komplett verlegen. Man musste also die erste Phase der Mission von Bahneinschuss bis hin zur Landung auf dem Titanen komplett ändern, wirklich komplett umstricken.
Aha, das heißt die ganze Missionsplanung bis dahin war quasi für die Kats und man musste es anders machen, damit dieser Frequenz ausgleich. Man hat sozusagen eigentlich einen falschen Weg genommen, durch den sich eine falsche Frequenz ergeben hätte, aber durch diesen Doppler-Effekt wiederum, den man vorher nicht bedacht hat, hat sich das genau wiederum ausgeglichen, sodass man mit Cassini auf der richtigen Frequenz empfangen konnte.
Ja, so kann man es ausdrücken. Man musste in viel größerer Empfang vorbeifliegen mit dem Cassini am Titanen und außerdem so, dass man rechtwinkig vorbeifliegt und nicht genau hinter dem Huygens, also hinter dem Huygens her, mit einer sehr kurzen Empfang, sondern in großem Abstand rechtwinkig vorbeifliegen, sodass sich der Doppler-Effekt eben nicht bemerkbar macht.
Da hat sich jemand in Ordnung verdient, oder?
Da hat sich jemand in Ordnung verdient, ja. Ich hoffe, den hat er auch gekriegt. Ich war es nicht, ich kann mir da keine, nicht auf die Schulter klopfen, aber...
Aber das hat die Mission gerettet, eigentlich.
Ich kann mir vor... Also, wenn ich mir vorstelle, wie blöd wir dargestellt hätten, wenn wir das erst gemerkt hätten, als nach der erfolgten Landung hinterher nur Müll runterkommt. Da wären wir jetzt gesperrter Leute gewesen. So waren wir halt... Also, das ist bemerkenswert, wie in der Raumfahrt Erfolg und kompletter Misserfolge, also lächerlicher Misserfolge, wie dicht das beisammen liegt. Da ein bisschen Glück, ein bisschen Glück und einmal aufgepasst statt geschlammt oder umgekehrt, das macht ihm den Unterschied aus.
Das Huygens-Problem wurde gelöst?
Wurde zum Glück gelöst, ja.
So, also, fass noch mal kurz zusammen. Also, Huygens hängt an Cassini dran und beide gehen jetzt fliegen auf den Titan zu und relativ früh wird Huygens jetzt in der richtigen Richtung, zum richtigen Zeitpunkt abgesetzt. Cassini selbst bringt sich dann wiederum aus dieser Annäherungsphase heraus durch entsprechende Manöver, bleibt aber eben so auf Sicht, dass die Daten empfangen werden können und durch diesen Trick, das Umgehen des Huygens-Problems auch auf der richtigen Frequenz empfangen kann. Huygens rauscht jetzt auf den Titan zu. Bis zur Annäherung an diese Atmosphäre, die jetzt, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, 1000 Kilometer dicht ist.
Etwas über 1000 Kilometer, ja gut. Ich meine, Atmosphäre hat ja kein Schild, wo steht hier, fängt die Atmosphäre an.
Ja klar, aber im Vergleich zur Erde ist es so das Zehnfache an Dicke. Und irgendwann schalten sich dann eben alle Geräte ein und ab dem Moment wird dann alles aufgenommen, was sich irgendwie einem bietet. Was ist denn jetzt noch mal drin? Also eine Kamera, das haben wir schon erwähnt, aber das ist ja nicht das einzige Instrument.
Genau, also okay, es sind ja alle Sinne erfasst. Vor allen Dingen muss man sagen, die Geräte schalten sich ein. Und der Hitzeschild wird abgeworfen, denn der Hitzeschild umschließt das ganze Gebilde und wenn der umschlossen wird, dann können die Geräte ja nicht nach außen schauen. Also das muss richtig abgespalten werden, abgetrennt werden und die Sonde wird dadurch freigelegt und hängt am Fallschirm und geht runter. Huygens war, was viele Leute falsch verstanden haben oder nicht wissen, Huygens war primär eine atmosphärische Sonde. Also das war die Mission. Die Mission war, die Atmosphäre des Titan zu untersuchen. Die Oberflächenphase war eine reine Dreieingabe. Da hat man schon 100 Prozent der Mission erfüllt, dadurch, dass man landen konnte. So, was man hatte, war die Kamera. Was man hatte, war ein Mikrofon, um zu hören, ob man vielleicht Donner oder Blitz, also Gewittertätigkeit hat. Was man hatte, war ein Thermometer. Was man hatte, war ein Instrument, um beim Aufprall die Festigkeit der Oberfläche zu messen. Und was man vor einigen hatte, und das war jetzt ein sehr wichtiges Instrument, ist der Gas-Kormatograph-Massenspektrometer. Das ist im Prinzip so was, wie sie am Flughafen auch haben, wie wir am Flughafen auch haben, wie was man so kennt, um um Sprengstoff festzustellen, in sehr geringen, die Ausgasung von Sprengstoffen in sehr geringen Mengen. Also da kann man ganz geringe Mengen von Material, kann man ganz genau feststellen, da ist jetzt das und das und das und das und das drin, in dem Gas, das man nimmt. Da wurde also Außengas angesaugt, wurde erhitzt und wurde dann praktisch untersucht und da konnte man feststellen, da sind jetzt diese chemischen Verbindungen und diese Atome drin.
Das heißt, Huygens traf jetzt, also traf auf die Atmosphäre aus, also die Atmosphäre fing an zu existieren, wurde immer dichter, immer dichter, dadurch entsteht eine enorme Reibung, deswegen hat Huygens einen, also Huygens sieht ja aus wie so ein kleiner Topfkreisel.
So kleinlich, also der Durchmesser vom Hitzeschild war über zweieinhalb Meter und die eigentliche Sonne ist wie so ein Kupferkessel da in den Asterix-Häften, so kommen sie auch von der Form her, auch von der Größe.
Auch vom Inhalt her. Und okay, und dieser Hitzeschild wurde dann wann abgelegt, also war das dann eine Frage der Geschwindigkeitsverringerung?
Ja, das war genau, das war durch die Detektoren, die die Abrämsung feststellten. Also es wurde abgesprengt bei, als man sich unter anderthalbfacher Schallgeschwindigkeit bewegte, wurde erst der hintere Teil abgesprengt durch einen anderen, also durch Sprengbolzen und dann wurde mit einem Sprengsatz ein kleiner Fallschirm rausgezogen und der zog den halbgroßen Fallschirm raus und zog praktisch die eigentliche Sonde, diesen Kupferkessel, von dem Hitze-Schild weg. Dadurch der Hitze-Schild flog weiter.
Also der Hitze-Schild war vorne und hinten, das Ding war eigentlich komplett eingeschüttet.
Vorne war der Hitze-Schild, hinten war der Rückteil, der hintere Teil und der vordere Teil, das war der wirkliche Hitze-Schild, der vor der Abbremsung, also vor der wirklichen Hitze schützte. Der flog einfach weiter und der Fallschirm zog praktisch die Sonde nach hinten weg, brenzte also mehr ab und der Fallschirm war so ausgelegt, dass er, der wurde dann abgetrennt und wurde durch einen kleineren Fallschirm ersetzt, weil man Angst hatte, dass sonst der Abstieg so lange dauern würde, dass die Batterien, also man wollte auch die Unteratmosphäre, die dichte Unteratmosphäre untersuchen und selbst so hat der Abstieg drei Stunden gedauert. Und man hatte halt Angst, wenn man diesen großen Fallschirm dran lässt, dann würde es so lange dauern, dass dann der Cassini die Daten nicht mehr empfangen kann und dass die Batterien leer sind.
Man wusste ja jetzt nicht wirklich, wie dicht diese Atmosphäre ist. Gab es denn überhaupt noch irgendeine... Also man hat quasi darauf gewettet, dass man so die richtige Dimension von Fallschirmen gewählt hat, damit dieser Abstieg so schnell geht, wie man ihn gerne hätte.
Ja, man hat eben diese Sternenabdeckungsmessung und man hat Modellrechnungen. Aber eben Rechnungen sind eine Sache und die Realität ist eine andere.
Und wie nah war man dran an der Realität?
Zumindest war man gut genug dran, dass die Raumsonde Huygens den Aufprall, also den Abstieg gemacht hat, dabei das wissenschaftliche Programm durchlaufen hat, in den etwas über drei Stunden und dann den Aufprall überlebt hat und auf der Oberfläche immer noch weiter gesendet hat.
Wie lange dann noch?
Wissen wir nicht. Also wir haben Datenempfang hier, nee, Daten haben wir nicht, wir haben Signale empfangen mit Teleskopen auf der Erde. Mit Teleskopen konnte man, also Radioteleskopen, konnte man feststellen, da sendet jemand in der Frequenz vom Titan.
Aber nicht mehr was?
Das konnte man leider nicht, da war die Empfang zu groß und das Rauschen war zu, der Rauschabstand war zu gering. Man konnte also keine Daten daraus holen, aber man konnte wirklich feststellen, nicht nur das gesendet wird, sondern auch wo gesendet wird auf dem Titan. Also man konnte mit Überlagung, sogenannte Interferometrie, dass mehrere Teleskope gleichzeitig diese Signale empfangen, konnte man daraus rückrechnen, wo genau, wie genau sich jetzt der Huygens da unter seinem Fallschirm, getrieben vom Wind, auf die Oberfläche zugewischt. Ganz bemerkenswert.
Also wirklich während der Landung?
Während der Landung, auf Kilometer genau, konnte man verfolgen, wie der da runtergeht.
Und wie lange war der Kontakt zwischen Cassini und Huygens?
Der Kontakt zwischen Cassini und Huygens war etwas über fünf Stunden und dann war Cassini unter dem Horizont verschwunden. Der flog ja dann weiter.
Aber zu dem Zeitpunkt war Huygens noch funktionsfähig?
Ja, Huygens war danach sogar noch funktionsfähig. Wir haben die Signale immer noch weiter empfangen. Und irgendwann war dann keine Bodenstation mehr zu empfangen, weil am Pazifik sind keine großen Radioteleskopen mehr. Und wir wussten, dass er noch weitersendet. Aber wir wussten nicht, wie lange noch. Weil als dann die nächsten Radioteleskopen wieder hochkamen, war er verstummt. Da waren die Batterien eben aufgebraucht.
Nach wie viel Stunden?
Also wir hatten, ich glaube, wir hatten über sechs Stunden insgesamt Sende, Sendung, Signale empfangen.
Das heißt, hätte man jetzt noch mehr Teleskope auf der Erde gehabt, hätte man noch länger Signale, aber keine Daten mehr empfangen können.
Das war dann, da war er schon auf der Oberfläche, also das ist dann nicht, das wäre höchstens noch technisch interessant, dass man weiß, wie lange die Batterien durchhalten.
Aber anders gesprochen, über die maximal möglichen Zeitraum von fünf Stunden, konnten auch wirklich Daten empfangen werden. Und das war schon mehr, als man eigentlich hätte sich wünschen können. Das waren die Häubchen und Schokolade noch drauf. Also Kamera, was hat die Kamera gesehen?
Die Kamera hat schwarz-weiß-Bilder gemacht und man hat eine Lampe an Bord gehabt, die eine Fluoreszenz erzeugt, also eine Reflektion, die also Gas in der Umgebung anregte, sodass man eben kalibrieren konnte. Man konnte also wirklich mit einem Farbmessgerät, konnte man wirklich feststellen, was hat es da von der Umgebung gegeben. Es war so ein orangefarbenes Licht, durch das Methan war das so ein orangenes Licht, war so ein orangenes Licht getaucht auf der Oberfläche. Und die Kamera hat während des Abstiegsbilders gemacht.
Wie muss man sich das vorstellen mit Licht? Also wir haben vorhin schon gesagt, da kommt gerade noch mal ein Prozent des Sonnenlichtes an im Vergleich zur Erde. Zu dem Zeitpunkt der Landung gab es auch direkte Sonneneinstrahlung.
Ja, das war die Seite, die direkt zur Sonne also praktisch voll illuminiert war, voll beleuchtet. Sonst hätten wir auch die Daten, die die Funksieger nicht empfangen können. Also was die Sonne sieht, sieht sie oder wenn die die sonnenbeleuchtete Seite ist, ist praktisch die Seite, die die Erde sieht. Und während des Abstiegs, das Problem war nicht so sehr, dass man kein Licht hätte. Also es immer noch mehr als in der Mondnacht hier auf der Erde, heller da, auf dem Titan. Das Problem war, dass eben in großer Höhe durch Wolken und Dunst die Oberfläche nicht zu sehen ist. Aber es ging, also wir hatten wirklich gute Sicht auf die Oberfläche. Man konnte sehen, dass man praktisch, also einen Wissenschaftler, den habe ich gefragt, wenn sie jetzt auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10 bewerten würden, dieser Landestelle, wie würden sie das sagen? Wo 1 schlecht ist und 10 gut, dann würde er sagen, hat er gesagt, 11. Wir sind wirklich an der Grenze gelandet. Ich sage immer wir, weil ich praktisch so mitfühle, als ob ich da mit gelandet wäre. Huygens ist da gelandet an der Grenze zwischen dem Hochland, das ist so hell, und dem Tiefland, das ist dunkel, das ist wie so ein ausgetrocknetes Seebett.
Hell jetzt von außen betrachtet, hell, oder ist es hell, weil da mehr Sonnenlicht landet?
Nein, nein, es ist hell gefärbt. Das Erstaunliche war, das ist mir damals schon so aufgefallen, ich bin auch da unter einem Interview geworden von irgendwelchen Leuten, da haben die mich gefragt, was sehen sie denn da? Also alle haben eigentlich praktisch gesagt, was wir da sehen, ist ja gar nichts besonderes, wir sehen doch da eine Küstenlandschaft, wir sehen Flüsse, Flüsse, die zusammenfließen, die sich da in das Meer ergießen, das ist doch gar nichts besonderes, das ist praktisch wie eine schlecht aufgelöste, eine erdische Landschaft. Und da hab ich gesagt, Mensch, das ist doch grad das Besondere, dass man da so weit rausfliegt und da so was, und praktisch etwas sieht, das aussieht wie auf der Erde. Das ist doch das Außergewöhnliche. Das sah wirklich so aus, wie so eine, ja man sah Flüsse, man sah eindeutig Flüsse, man sah, wie die zusammenfließen, man sah, wie die sich, ihr Bild, man sah Erosion, man sah, wie sich da so eine, wie da so eine, ja eine Küste ist und wie, wie das, wie das dunkle weitergeht mit ein paar Inseln drin. Was fehlte ist ja praktisch jetzt noch die Autobahn und die McDonalds- Schilder. Das ist doch, das ist doch wirklich, man, wir fliegen so weit und sehen, ja wie in diesem Film, in weiter Ferne so nah. Das ist doch wirklich, das ist doch das bemerkenswertste, das setzt man sich auf den Hintern und macht den Mund auf. Ja, das war wirklich das, wo man mir praktisch den Kiefer zuklappen musste. Ich hätte ja alles erwartet, aber nicht das.
Also wie so eine kleine Erde, bloß alles anders.
Alles anders, ja.
Es gab Flüsse, es gab Berge, Teler und Lehen, bloß alles mit Methan und alles mit Eis. Leider war die Auflösung nicht besonders hoch.
Naja, das wussten wir vorher. Es war halt die Auflösung, die diese Kamera machte. Das war so einige 100 Pixel, aber das muss man zusammensetzen. Und das Dumme war, dass die ersten Bilder, die wir hatten, die waren ja natürlich nur einzelne Bilder und in Wirklichkeit drehte sich dieser Huygens unter seinem Fallschirm. Da waren ja extra so Luftleitbäche drin, die eine Rotation hervorriefen und die Bilder mussten dann aufwendig zusammengepatcht werden.
Warum die Rotation, um das Ding weiter zu stabilisieren?
Nein, damit man eben nicht nur eine Seite sieht.
Achso, damit man die Beine hinkriegt.
Und das war, aber was man natürlich auch noch hatte, war unter dem Fallschirm natürlich bei der hohen Geschwindigkeit am Anfang war ein Schaukel hin und her. Und das muss man erst rausrechnen. Also das ist natürlich eine hochgradig komplexe Bewegung, wie so ein Torquender betrunken. Und das muss man natürlich erst mal bewerkstelligen. Die Bilder waren auf Wegen, die eigentlich nicht so ganz nachvollziehbar sind. Das sollte eigentlich nicht so sein. Ich glaube, die Wissenschaftler, die wollten die Bilder nicht so ins Netz stellen, aber es ist trotzdem passiert aus irgendwelchen Gründen, gleich am selben Tag noch. Und am nächsten Tag hatte man schon, selbst am nächsten Tag hatte man schon Bilder, die nachbearbeitet waren, die wirklich in sehr hoher Qualität wiedergaben, was man da sah. Also wo wir gelandet sind, sah man große Steine, kleine Steine, man sah praktisch wie so eine Auswaschung und hinten ging es weiter, da waren dann auch Steine und die waren alle sehr abgerundet. Würde ich eigentlich jetzt nicht so erwarten. Abgerundete Steine, das sieht ja aus wie ein Flussbett, die sind abgerundet. Und die Steine waren natürlich keine Steine, die waren Eisbrocken. Aber die müssen ja bewegt worden sein von Flüssigkeit. Das war das Interessante.
Das allein das weist schon auf richtige Flussaktivität hin.
Ja, da man sah, ich habe schon an solchen Stränden gelegen, da habe ich natürlich geärgert, wenn der wenig Sand und viele Steine. Aber das sind wirklich Szenen, wo man sich überlegt, hm, das kenne ich doch. Ja, also mittlerweile hat Cassini natürlich dann mit seinem Radar und mit seinen Infrarot-Instrumenten, also Infrarot ist nicht das einzige, was diese dicke Dunstlocke dadurch dringen kann, festgestellt, dass es nicht nur ausgetrocknete Seen, sondern wirkliche Seen gibt, also wirklich so groß wie diese Seen da in den USA, diese großen Seen, da in den Erie, Huron, Oberer See, Superior und so weiter wie Illinois. Von der Größe, also nicht nur kleine Teiche, sondern wirklich große Seen aus Kohlenwasserstoffen gibt es auf dem Titan.
Das hat die Kamera aufgenommen. Was haben denn die Mikrofone zur Kenntnis genommen?
Die Mikrofone haben leider keine Gewittertätigkeit aufgenommen. Aber ich muss sagen, als ich dieses Pfeifen des vorbeirauschenden Windes beim Abstieg gehört habe, da standen mir wirklich die Haare zu berge. Das war ein Geräusch von so weit weg. Unvorstellbar eigentlich. Das war eigentlich das, was mich emotional am meisten berührt hat, dieses Geräusch da zu hören. Es war einfach so ein kaltes Pfeifen. Es war einfach der Fahrtwind von der absteigenden Sonde. Aber allein das man das so hört, das ist...
Und da hat man auch Aufnahmen von dem Zeitpunkt, wo die Sonde dann aufgeschlagen war?
Ja, da ist ja... also man hat ja da keine große Aktivität mehr. Da hat man vorwiegend die chemische Analyse gemacht. Da hat man wirklich gesehen. Und das war bemerkenswert, dass durch die Energie, die Wärme, die diszipiert wird von der Sonne, die ist ja wärmer als die Umgebung. Die Umgebung ist ja minus 180 Grad, wirklich kalt da unten, 90 Kelvin. Da wurden Kohlenwasserstoffe freigesetzt. Also die Umgebung veränderte sich während der Zeit, als Huygens da saß und nichts mehr machte. Und das hat... das konnte man durch den Gaschromatographen verstellen. Natürlich wurden in der ganzen Zeit immer noch Bilder gemacht. Da sah man zum Beispiel auf den Bildern hinterher, sah man, wie hinterher der Fallschirm, der Schatten des Fallschirms, vorbeizog, der dann woanders landete.
Ich hab hier mal den Sound mir mal geschnappt. Vielleicht können wir mal kurz mal reinhören hier. Also das ist jetzt sozusagen die Sonde, wie sie auf der Oberfläche sich nähert.
Ja, mit hunderten Kilometern pro Stunde absinkt, wahrscheinlich da schon langsamer, aber eben doch der Fahrtwind, der ziemlich heftig vorbeirauscht.
Welchen Belastungen ist denn die Sonde dann noch ausgesetzt gewesen? Also es ist ja, die Atmosphäre hat, muss ja, also gut, man hat ja diesen Hitzeschild, damit hat man sich schon mal geschützt. Ab einer bestimmten Geschwindigkeit war es dann sozusagen freigesetzt. Hatte man irgendwie eine Vorstellung davon, was da alles noch in Konflikt geraten kann mit der Sonde?
Also man hatte ein bisschen Sorge wegen, also man hat ja schon vorher gesagt, na vielleicht trifft er ja auf den Ozean, das ist jetzt nicht so eingetreten. Aber man hatte sich gedacht, also den Aufschlag, das sind dann einige Meter pro Sekunde, wenn es das mal übersteht, aber das war eigentlich gar nicht das Problem. Also das hat sich völlig unbeschadet überstanden.
Weil es einfach so stabil gebaut war?
Ja, weil es auch nicht so schlimm war. Also im Prinzip ist Huygens Titan einer ziemlich zahmen Umgebung ausgesetzt gewesen, muss man wirklich mal so sagen. Also die Atmosphäre ist ja so dick, bei Mars ist es viel schlimmer, da ist die Atmosphäre dünn. Das heißt, man kommt da rein und dann tritt man da voll auf die Bremse. Und beim Huygens ist das alles, obwohl die Einzigeschwindigkeit vergleichbar ist, die ganze Belastung ist über eine viel größere Strecke ausgedehnt und da kann man eigentlich nicht so viel falsch machen. Also, naja, also...
Landet Butterweich.
Ja, landet Butterweich und der Falscher, wer macht das denn schon? Auf dem Huygens hatten wir zum Beispiel keine Bremsraketen oder Airbags oder so, braucht man alles gar nicht. Auf dem Mars braucht man die unbedingt.
Ein Thermometer war noch drauf?
Thermometer war natürlich drauf.
Was für Temperaturen herrschen dort?
Ja, das ist eben die Frage. Also, minus 90 Grad, minus 180 Grad, etwa so um die 90 Kelvin, ja, 90 Grad, nur über dem absoluten Nullpunkt. Das ist kalt, das ist kalt, muss ich sagen. Der Weltraum hat ja keine Temperatur. Ich meine, Temperatur ist ja nur, in dem Sinne, Temperatur ist ja die Anwesenheit von kalter Materie. Im Weltraum habe ich das Problem ja nicht. Da habe ich ja gar nichts. Da ist nur Strahlungsgleichgewicht. Aber wenn ich jetzt umgegeben bin von ganz kalter Materie, dann muss ich wirklich ordentlich isolieren. Sonst wird das Rückzug so kalt, passt sich das der Umgebungstemperatur an.
Und war dann Huygens entsprechend noch?
War gut gepolstert und war innen ja geheizt durch die durch die durch erstmal so kleine sogenannte RHUs. Das sind einfach kleine Keramik-Fropfen, wo ein bisschen radioaktives Material drin ist. So zwei Gramm radioaktives Material und davon waren einige verteilt und die erzeugen nur Wärme.
Hat einfach so vor sich hin geglüht.
Ja, geglüht nicht. Also es hat ein bisschen Wärme erzeugt. Und die Batterien selbst natürlich elektronische Geräte erzeugen, wie jeder Computerbenutzer weiß, auch Wärme. Da drin war es so relativ warm noch. Das war okay. Also zumindest, die Batterien waren ja ausgelegt. Wir hatten fünf Batterien an Bord und die waren so ausgelegt, dass man sagte, okay, eine gibt wahrscheinlich den Löffel ab beim Eintritt, davon müssen wir ausgehen. Entweder wird die zu kalt oder zu warm. Und eine andere, die wird vielleicht noch so ein bisschen angeknackst sein und von den drei müssen wir die Mission noch hinkriegen. Und was passiert ist, dass alle fünf im Ende völlig unbeschadet überstanden haben. Deswegen haben wir auch die lange Lebensdauer gehabt.
Woher weiß man das? Das war so Teil der Daten, wie viele Batterien noch funktionieren.
Ja, das weiß man eben. Das war Teil der Telemetrie und das war auch, es gibt sich auch die Lebensdauer alleine.
Dieser Massenspektrometer, dieser Gaskromatograph, der dürfte ja dann eigentlich die interessantesten Ergebnisse für die Wissenschaftler gebogen haben.
Das ist der Schnüffler, das ist also, das sind sogar Nase sozusagen. Ja. Das ist sicher, das ist immer ground truth und damit, es gibt nichts, was Institutdaten ersetzt. Da kann ihnen einer erzählen, was er will, was er alles Tolles aus dem Orbit misst. Ist ja auch schön und gut, aber es gibt halt nichts besseres als hinzugehen und sein Messgerät da weg ranzuhalten. Das ist durch nichts zu ersetzen.
Waren denn die Ergebnisse so, wie man sich das gedacht hat?
In der Wissenschaft sucht man ja nie nach Ergebnissen, die so sind, wie man sich das gedacht hat, sondern die so sind, wie sie sind. Das ist die grundlegende Sache. Wenn man anfängt zu suchen nach dem, was man sich gedacht hat, dann macht man wahrscheinlich schon einen Fehler. Wenn man dann von vornherein filtert, was man sieht, sollte man nicht tun. Man hat zum einen den Kryovolkanismus festgestellt, das war sicherlich nicht unbedingt erhofft oder erwartet. Das war nicht mein Künstenträum. Aber was man feststellen wollte, ist auch die Herkunft des Methanen. Da ist es wieder eine Frage, dass das ganze Methan, das man hat in der Atmosphäre, wahrscheinlich nicht biologischen Ursprungs. Da kann man dadurch feststellen, dass man sich die Massenanteile an Kohlenstoff 12 und Kohlenstoff 13 anschaut. Wichtig war auch, dass man feststellen wollte, was es noch für andere Kohlenwasserstoffverbindungen gab und eben nicht nur Methan, sondern auch Ethan und andere Produkte aus dem Zerfall von Methan, die sich hinterher zusammengesetzt haben. Oder wie sich Methan, also Kohlenwasserstoffbauteile, hinterher mit Stickstoffverbindungen zusammenfinden. Und das sind halt Sachen, ob man sich das gedacht hat, weiß ich nicht, das wollte man halt rauskriegen. Das ist wirklich eine Sache, wo man wirklich wenig wusste vorher.
Aber auf jeden Fall hat auch dieser Sinn funktioniert.
Also die Menge an Daten ist überwältigend. Und die Qualität der Daten ist auch überwältigend. Und allein das, dass man diesen planetenähnlichen Mond, wirklich planetenähnlichen Mond viel besser verstanden hat als dieses ganz, ganz grobe Bild, das man vorher hatte, ist ein ganz gewaltiger Sprung vorwärts.
Wie ist denn, wir haben ja eingangs so über diesen Apollo-Effekt geredet und nun mal ist es ja auch schon so, Huygens, das ist jetzt so eine der größeren Ereignisse der Raumfahrt gewesen, wo sagen wir mal zumindest innerhalb der Raumfahrtszene die Wahrnehmung war. Ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass Huygens genauso in das historische Gedächtnis der Erdbevölkerung so eingebrannt ist, wie das jetzt eben die Mondmission war, weil die war natürlich greifbarer. Menschen hüpften da rum, haben irgendwie kluge Dinge gesagt, das ist natürlich bei solchen Messergebnissen ein ganz anderer Blick, aber vielleicht auch so innerhalb der ESA oder auch innerhalb der Raumfahrtgemeinde kannst du das vielleicht nochmal ein bisschen darstellen, wie da die Wahrnehmung einer solchen Mission ist, wie wirkt so ein Projekt auf diese ganze Gemeinschaft?
Ich kann nur sagen, dass die Leute, die irgendwie wussten, dass ich an der Mission arbeite, in dieser Mission arbeite, dass ich da unheimlich viele Anrufe von Leuten gekriegt hab, irgendeinem Vorwand, mein Versicherungsmakler oder so, die haben irgendwas angerufen und haben dann, dann stellte sich aber ziemlich schnell heraus, die wollten gar nicht über das andere reden, sondern die wollten wissen, was da jetzt Sache ist. Und auch an dem Tag der Landung von Huygens auf Titan, da war hier alles voll mit Journalisten aus aller Welt. Journalisten aus aller Welt, Chinesen, Japaner, Amerikaner, Europäer, von überall her, Südamerikaner. Das war wirklich bemerkenswert, das hab ich noch nie erlebt, sowas. Und auch das war wirklich ein Zeichen dafür, dass das eben nicht so ein alltägliches Ereignis ist, sondern das war wirklich etwas, was dem die Leute Bedeutung beimahs. Selbst an dem Tag der Landung, da war eine ganz komische Atmosphäre überall, weil wirklich Stress und Entspannung da war. Selbst die Reinigungskräfte hier im ESOC, die jetzt nicht mit der täglichen Arbeit zu tun haben und die vielleicht auch nicht so gut Deutsch oder Englisch können, gar nicht Englisch können und vielleicht nur ein bisschen Deutsch, die haben dann versucht zu fragen, was ist denn los und wie sieht es denn aus und was passiert denn? Und dann habe ich denen das erklärt und das fand ich ganz toll. Und einer von den Wachleuten hat seine Tochter mitgebracht, die war noch 13 Jahre alt oder so, die war richtig fast noch nervöser als ich. Die hat sich das überhaupt nicht nehmen lassen, da jetzt unbedingt mitzukommen und sich das aus erster Hand alles zu erfahren. Und das sind so Sachen, die weisen darauf hin, dass für mich sind sie ein Zeichen dafür, dass es eben wirklich was Besonderes war. Das habe ich so noch nicht erlebt. Das ist eben nicht nur etwas, was man mal so konsumiert, was man sich immer anschaut, sondern es war wirklich was, was man von vornherein, was man vorher schon wahrnimmt, dass man schon fern am Horizont näher kommen sieht. Und gerade das, also auch hinterher, denn das Presseecho, das Medienecho, da waren ja überall diese Bilder von, dieses erste Bild von der Oberfläche, dieses orange hinterlegte, wo man diese merkwürdige doch erdähnliche Landschaft sah mit den Eisbrocken. Das fand sich ja wirklich in jeder Zeitung, die Kantine war getapiziert mit Zeitungsausschnitten in allen, praktisch in allen Sprachen. Das war auch neu eigentlich für mich, das hab ich so noch nicht erlebt.
Und was geht in einem selbst so vor, wenn man jetzt nach so einer langen Zeit, ich meine, wann war das erste Mal, warst du von Anfang an bei dieser Mission mit dabei?
Das wär gut, ja. Nee, leider nicht. Ich war eigentlich richtig dabei erst seit ungefähr 2000. Also als das losging mit der Entdeckung dieses Huygens-Problems und der Umgestaltung der Mission, da war ich beteiligt.
Und welche Rolle hast du konkret jetzt eingenommen innerhalb des Huygens-Projektes?
Ich war Missionsanalytiker, ich hab an den Bahnberechnungen teilgenommen, die die ESA-Seite betrafen, also die Huygens betrafen. Aber leider war eben, als ich dazustehe, war die Lösung des Huygens-Problems, das hatte schon jemand anders gemacht. Schade, das wär echt interessant gewesen, Krönung der Karriere sozusagen. Aber es war schon interessant, also es war praktisch das Interface auf der Missionsanalyseseite zwischen den Leuten, also zwischen Huygens und den NASA-Leuten.
Aber trotzdem hat sich das sozusagen bei mehrere Jahre begleitet, zwei, drei Jahre. Was geht da so in einem vor, wenn das dann auf einmal so passiert ist? Oder was geht in einem vor, wenn es erstmal passiert, ausgesehen von der Anspannung?
Man ist da halt drin. Das ist halt nicht nur irgendwas, was man nur so aufnimmt, sondern das ist halt man selbst. Ich habe auch, nicht nur bei mir, ich habe gesehen, andere Leute, die Ingenieure, die schon seit den späten 80ern dabei waren, die kenne ich, also Franzosen, zum Beispiel.
Also die das Ganze sozusagen von der Urplanung her begleitet haben.
Genau, die praktisch jede Schraube kennen, die sind an Tränen aufgelöst gewesen, gestandene Männer. Da gibt es auch noch Fotos davon. Ich halte sie manchmal vor und das ist wirklich so, dass sich da die Spannung, die sich da aufgestaut hat, löst. Ein anderes Bild, das ist mir auch noch.
20 Jahre des eigenen Lebens, vielleicht ein Großteil des Arbeitslebens, die diese ganze Mission bedeutet.
Kann sich dann gar nichts anderes mehr erinnern. Ich kann mich auch in einem anderen Fall erinnern, also bei der Landung ist ja ein Datenkanal nicht da gewesen. Wir hatten zwei redundante Datenkanäle und auf dem einen Datenkanal, da war nun gerade ein Datensatz drauf, ich will jetzt nicht in Details geben, was das war, aber der Wissenschaftler davon, der hat praktisch sein ganzes Leben, also seine, nicht sein Lebenswerk, aber zumindest das, worauf er hingearbeitet hatte, diese Daten zu empfangen, die hat er nicht gehabt. Und der Mann, der arme, der tat mir so leid, der saß da auf dem Stuhl, die Leute, die Menge brandete um ihn rum und der saß da und war einfach völlig am Boden zerstört.
Alle haben bekommen, was sie wollten, nur er nicht.
Naja, also der war wirklich zerschmettert, der Mann.
Aber es sind ja nun auch einige Daten geflossen. Was haben denn jetzt die Daten, die in der Atmosphäre aufgezeichnet wurden und ausgewertet werden konnten, was konnte man denn da nun alles herauslesen?
Es ist alles nur noch ein Puzzlestück und man nimmt diese Daten und versucht damit, Modelle abzugleichen vom Aufbau dieses Planeten. Also es ist alles, im Endeffekt ist es eine Frage davon, dass man Modelle, Computermodelle erstellen kann, die den Planeten beschreiben, wie er es innen aufgebaut, wie ist seine Atmosphäre aufgebaut, wie funktioniert der Austausch von Energie, wie funktioniert der chemische Austausch, wie funktioniert der Austausch mit der Oberfläche, also was da runter regnet und dann von der Oberfläche aus verdunstet und sich wieder in die Atmosphäre reinbringt. Das muss man mit Modellen erfassen. Wichtig ist es deswegen, wenn man versteht, wie so ein Körper funktioniert, dann hat man sehr viele Informationen darüber, wie überhaupt sich Himmelskörper überhaupt bilden können. Wir haben ja wirklich nur Daten von der Erde, haben wir jede Menge Daten und darüber hinaus wird es dann ein bisschen trübe. Das ist ja ein bisschen wenig und wenn wir jetzt verstehen wollen, sind wir wirklich allein im Weltall. Wir wissen jetzt von anderen, von dieser Kepler-Raumsonne, die jetzt tausende von anderen Exoplaneten schon festgestellt hat und immer kleinere findet, dass es wahrscheinlich sehr, sehr viele, also Millionen, hunderte von Millionen erdähnlichen Planeten geben muss irgendwo.
Der erste ist jetzt auch schon bestätigt worden, der vielleicht nicht sehr erdähnlich ist, aber zumindest sich in denselben Dimensionen bewegt.
Das ist das Stichwort, genau, das ist das Stichwort. Und wenn man jetzt Modelle haben will, die die Planetenentstehung beschreiben, dann kann man das ja eigentlich nur machen, indem man das Weltteil, wie wir es kennen, mit unseren Raumsonden erfassen können, als Labor benutzt. Und dass man aus diesen Messdaten eben diese Computermodelle kalibriert. Das ist der Sinn der Sache und das ist der Wert von Cassini-Huygens. Das ist also praktisch, dass Huygens an der Stelle, wo Unwissenheit war, ein kleines bisschen Wissen reingebracht hat, ein kleines bisschen weniger Unwissenheit.
Das Projekt ist ja noch nicht abgeschlossen. Cassini dreht sich weiterhin munter um den Saturn herum und quält sich da zwischen den Monden herum. Heißt das, dass er dann auch immer am laufenden Meter immer wieder noch durch diese Ringe durchmanövriert wird?
Meistens, mittlerweile ist das Parallelzentrum schon hoch genug, dass man nicht mehr durch die Ringe durch muss, also durch die Zonen, natürlich auf keinen Fall durch die Zonen, wo die dichten, wo viele Staubteilchen sind. Durch die Ring-Ebene, ja, und die weiteren, also die Ringe, also Ringmaterial in geringeren Mengen findet sich auch noch sehr viel weiter draussen, da muss er schon immer durch, ja. Denn wir wissen jetzt, dass Enceladus, dieser Mond, der da Geysirer hat, tatsächlich zum Material nachführt, aus dem Ringe werden.
Das heißt, es wird immer mehr?
Nee, es wird nicht immer mehr, sondern es ist ein kontinuierlicher Prozess. Es kommt von außen was nach und gleichzeitig, da die Wandern durch Störungen der Bahn wandern, sie immer weiter nach innen und werden am Ende von Saturn verschluckt.
Ah, verstehe. Das heißt, würde nicht immer wieder nachgeführt werden, wären die Ringe vielleicht auch irgendwann weg?
Vielleicht sind die gar nicht so alt. Es gibt, ich weiß jetzt nicht, was der letzte Stand ist und wahrscheinlich wird, selbst wenn der letzte Stand heute so ist, wird er ein Jahr wieder anders aussehen, aber es gibt durchaus widersprüchliche Theorien über das Alter der Ringe.
Eine Menge los am Saturn.
Es ist eine Menge los, sehr interessant.
Wie lange wird denn Cassini noch fliegen?
Solange Geld da ist und solange noch Treibstoff da ist, dann ab und zu muss die Bahn nachgeriegelt werden. Die Sonde ist eigentlich in gutem Zustand, muss man sagen.
So sehr viel Geld muss ja dann gar nicht mehr hinzugeführt werden, um so ein Projekt am Leben zu erhalten.
Das stimmt.
Das ist wahrscheinlich nicht so das größte Problem.
Ja, die NASA ist in einem Zustand im Moment, dass man wirklich davon nicht mehr ausgehen kann, dass selbst Missionen, die eigentlich noch ganz gut laufen, weitergehen.
Und hat jetzt der Saturn nach Cassini-Huygens einen anderen Stellenwert bekommen, so in der Astroforschung ist man jetzt sozusagen auf den Geschmack gekommen, durch diese mindestens zwei besonderen Monde und die Ergebnisse der Messungen von Huygens?
Also es gab vor einigen Jahren einen Wettbewerb, eine Ausschreibung für eine weitere Forschung im äußeren Sonnensystem. Und da war es eine Konkurrenzsituation zwischen den Monden des Saturn, einer Mission, die die Monde des Saturn, also insbesondere Titan und Enceladus untersuchen sollte. Also eine Mission, die gerade das Saturnsystem unter besonderer Berücksichtigung von dem, was man gelernt hatte, von Cassini-Huygens, also Enceladus, insbesondere jetzt noch mal genauer unter die Lupe nehmen. Der eine Kandidat und der andere Kandidat war ein Europa-Lander. Europa ist ein Jupiter-Mond, von dem man ziemlich genau annehmen kann, also ziemliche Sicherheit annehmen kann, dass es unter einem Eispanzer einen ausgedehnten flüssigen Ozean gibt. Das ist die Warmsein muss durch gezeiten Kräfte durchgeknetet. Und es ist ein sehr guter Kandidat dafür, Leben zu finden. Wenn Saturn und seine Monde jetzt derartig aufgerückt sind, dass sie gegen so einen brandheißen Kandidaten immer noch bestehen können, dann will das ja schon was heißen. Mittlerweile hat man sich dann doch für die Jupiter-Mission entschieden. Und dummerweise ist es aus Geldmangel dazugekommen, dass die amerikanische Seite ihre Beteiligung, also diesen Europalander zurückgezogen hat. Das ist jetzt sehr schade, weil das wirklich eine ganz fundamentale Mission gewesen wäre.
Aber das schließt ja nicht aus, dass nicht in Zukunft auch weitere Fernmissionen gestartet werden, auch wenn jetzt erstmal konkret so nichts auf dem Weg zur Startbahn ist.
Ich glaube, die Amerikaner untersuchen jetzt eine Möglichkeit, gerade in Zelladis und Titan noch mal mit einer reduzierten Aufwandsvolumen in die nähere Untersuchung zu nehmen. Ich weiß nicht, was der aktuelle Zustand ist, denn das weiß wahrscheinlich auch in der NASA keiner so genau. Da würde sich auch keiner aus dem Fenster lehnen jetzt eine klare Prognose treffen, denn die NASA ist mitten in der Umstrukturierung und wie das am Ende aussieht, wissen wir nicht. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass es eine gewagte Prognose ist, wenn man sagt, dass der Saturn und insbesondere Titan und die weiteren inneren Monde noch sehr viele Geheimnisse bergen, die wir nicht gelöst haben und die für die Planetologie eine wirklich wichtige Frage sind.
Aber Cassini-Huygens, das ist gelaufen bzw. läuft auch noch weiter. Das klang jetzt alles hier so unbeschwert irgendwie. Man berichtet zwar von Problemen, die man auf der Strecke gelöst hat, aber ist denn das, wenn man mit so einem Projekt beginnt, auf so eine riesige Distanz eine relativ gewagte Operation vorzunehmen, kann man so sagen, oder? Das war doch eigentlich ein gewagtes Unternehmen.
Das war ein sehr kühnes Unternehmen. Das muss man jetzt wirklich mal so honorieren, dass es einfach auch Kühnheit dazu gehört, jetzt mal so was anzugehen und durchzuziehen. Und der zeigt auch noch. Also wirklich innerhalb weniger einer Dekade von den ersten Konzepten bis zur Startreife. Das ist wirklich bemerkenswert.
Das sagt eigentlich eine Menge über alle Beteiligten aus, dass sie da auch gut an einem Strang gezogen haben.
Ja, das sagt was aus, das stimmt. Das zeigt eben auch, was man machen kann, wenn man eben nicht nur zaghaft ist und jetzt Bedenken anmeldet, sondern einfach sagt so, let's do it. Das ist wirklich die Denke, die wir brauchen, denke ich mal.
Dann sage ich vielen Dank für die Ausführungen hier zum Projekt Cassini-Huygens. Und auch vielen Dank fürs Zuhören bei Raumzeit. Das war die dreißigste Ausgabe. Sagt tschüss und bis bald.